hi everyone
welcome to this video tutorial on python
data analysis project for 2022 in this
video we'll be covering two interesting
hands-on projects using python
programming you will learn how to use
real-world data to perform data analysis
and data visualization the two projects
are based on coronavirus and olympics
data you will learn to collect analyze
clean manipulate and visualize data with
the help of python libraries such as
numpy pandas matplotlib and cbon these
two projects will give you the idea to
solve real-world problems using
exploratory data analysis so let's get
started with our first project
today we are going to perform two
hands-on projects on covet data analysis
using python and tableau
this is going to be a really interesting
and fun session where i'll be asking you
a few generic quiz questions related to
coronavirus please make sure to answer
them in the comments section of the
video we'll be happy to hear from you
covet or coronavirus is an ongoing
global pandemic of coronavirus disease
that emerged in 2019 and was first
identified in wuhan china
it is defined as an illness caused by a
novel coronavirus called severe acute
respiratory syndrome coronavirus 2
commonly known as sars cove 2.
on march 11 2020 the who declared coven
19 a global health emergency the virus
has so far infected over 22 crore people
and killed more than 4.5 million
innocents
in india there have been over 3.3 crore
confirmed cases and nearly
4 lakh 41 000 deaths have been reported
so far
this data is according to official
figures released by the union ministry
of health and family welfare
as the world tries to cope up with this
deadly virus we request all our viewers
and their family members to follow all
the necessary precautions to avoid
getting infected
quiz time
now let's see our first quiz in this
project
what does corona in corona virus mean
here are the options is it a beer
b respiratory is it c crown or is it d
sun
this is a very general question i'm sure
a lot of you may already know some of
you may not
please let us know your answers in the
comments section of the video we'll be
glad to hear from you
now in this video we will use
three different kobe 19 data sets and
perform data analysis using python and
tableau
the project will give you hands-on
experience working on real-world data
sets and how you can use the different
python libraries to analyze and
visualize data and draw conclusions
you will learn how to create different
plots in tableau and then make a
dashboard from the visuals
the project will give you an idea about
the impact of coronavirus globally in
terms of confirmed cases deaths reported
the number of recoveries as well as
active cases
we will also see how india has been
affected since the pandemic started and
dive into the different states and union
territories to learn more about the
kovid 19 influence and the vaccination
status
first let me show you the two data sets
that we'll be using
so for our first project using python
we'll be using the first two data sets
kovid 19 india and covet vaccine
statewide
let me open the two data sets
okay so this is the first data set you
can see here
we have
the date
we have the time
then we have the different state names
scroll down you can see we have kerala
tamil nadu delhi haryana rajasthan
punjab
telangana and other states
then we have something called as
confirmed indian national so actually
this
two data sets confirmed indian national
and confirmed foreign national we won't
be using so in the demo itself we'll be
dropping these two columns
what we are concerned about are the last
three columns
the
cured cases or the recoveries the number
of debts reported and then we have the
total number of confirmed cases
let me just
sort the b column that is the date
column so that you have an idea
about the recent data we have i'll
continue with the current selection
and
sort it you can see here
this is
till
11th of august 2021
so this data was collected from kegel it
has some discrepancies that we will see
in the demo the data is available for
free
we will provide the link to the data
sets in the description of the video so
please go ahead and download them
the visualizations and results that you
will see in the demo are based on the
data sets that we'll be using we haven't
pre-processed the data to remove
outliers or any missing values
now before i jump into the demo let me
show you the second data set that we are
going to use
okay so covet vaccine statewide is my
second data set
let me open it
there you go
so
this is the second data set that we'll
be using in the python
project you can see we have a column
called updated on then we have the
state again you can see here there are a
few discrepancies here
it has taken the country name and not
the state name below you can see there
are the
different state names
and
you can also see we have information
about the total doses administered
we have the sessions sites
first dose administered then we have the
second dose
then we have information about male and
female doses
you can see here the different
vaccines
administered covaxin and cova shield you
have sputnik v
and here are the different age groups as
well
and finally if you see we have
male individuals vaccinated the total
number of female individuals vaccinated
for a particular day
we have information about transgender
individuals vaccinated and finally we
have the total individuals vaccinated
each day
all right before we jump into the
hands-on part let's have a look at the
second quiz in this project
so
here is the second quiz question
which is the first country to start
covet vaccination for toddlers
is it a japan b israel c portugal or is
it d cuba this is a very recent
development that took place if you watch
daily news updates on coronavirus you
will be definitely able to answer the
question please give it a try and put
your answers in the comments section of
the video it is really important for our
viewers to know the right answer
all right
so now let's begin
with our demo
so i am on my jupyter notebook
so the first project we are going to use
python jupyter notebook
i'll just
rename this notebook as
kovid
data analysis
project
and click on rename
all right
so first and foremost
we need to import all the necessary
libraries that we are going to use so
first i am importing pandas as pd this
is for
data manipulation then we have numpy as
np
numpy is used for numerical computation
then we are importing
matplotlib c bond and plotly
these three libraries will be used for
plotting our data and creating
interesting visualizations finally i'm
also importing
my date time function
all right
so i'll hit shift enter to run the first
cell
now it's time
to load our first data set
which is related to
the coveted 19 cases in india for the
different states and union territories
so i'll create a variable called covet
underscore df dfs for data frame
i'll use my pandas library
and then
give the read underscore csv function
since our data sets are
csv files
and inside
double quotes i'll pass in the
location where my data sets are present
so i'll just copy this location
i'll paste it here
we'll change
the backslash to forward slash
and after that i'm going to give my
file name followed by the extension of
the file
i'll say kobed19
india.csv
let's go ahead and run it
all right
now
to see the first few
rows
of the data frame i'm going to use the
head function
i'll say head and within
brackets let's say i
pass in 10 which means i want to see the
first 10 rows of data
if i run it there you go
here you can see from 0
till 9 so we have 10 rows of information
and these are the different
column names you have s number
date time state or union territory then
you have confirmed indian national
confirmed foreign national cured cases
deaths reported and the confirmed cases
all right
now moving ahead
let's use the
info function to get some idea about
a data set
if i run it you can see here
it gives us the
total number of columns we have nine
columns
the total number of entries or the rows
we have 1810 rows of information
starting from 0 till
18109
you see here the different types of
variables or column names that we have
then it has information about the memory
usage as well
and this side you can see
the data types
cool
now we'll use another very important
function which is
to get
some idea about statistical analysis the
basic statistics about your data set for
that i will be using the describe
function
okay
so if you can see here
the describe function is for numerical
columns only
and you have the measures such as count
the mean standard deviation
maximum minimum the
25th percentile 50th percentile and the
75th percentile value
okay
now let's move ahead and import the
second data set
which is related to
vaccination
so i'll create a variable called vaccine
underscore df
i'll write pd dot
read underscore csv function which is
present in pandas
library i'll move to the top and i'll
copy the
file location and we'll change the name
of the file
copy this and
let me paste it here
and instead of kovid underscore 19
underscore india
i'm going to say
governed underscore
vaccine
underscore
statewide
okay
so this is the data set that we saw
covered underscore vaccine underscore
state wise
all right
let me run it
cool
and
let's display the first
seven rows of information from this data
frame
i'll be using the head function and
inside the function i'll pass in 7
there you go so here you can see we have
from 0 till 6 there are total
24 columns
a lot of them have null values you can
see here
all right
now
from the first data set which is the
covet underscore df data frame
we'll be dropping a few
unnecessary
columns such as the time column
confirmed indian national and conformed
foreign national as well as the s number
we don't need these columns so it's
better
to learn how to drop the columns for our
analysis
so i'll say
kovid underscore df
dot
i'll use the
drop function
and within square brackets i'll pass in
the
column names the first is s number
i'll give a comma
within double quotes i'll say the next
column is time
my third column that i want to drop is
confirmed
indian national
give another comma
within double quotes i'll say
confirmed
foreign national
outside the
square brackets i'll give another comma
and pass in my next
argument
that is in place equal to i'll say true
i'll give another comma and say
axis
equal to 1.
let's run it
okay it has thrown an error let's debug
the error
says confirmed indian okay it should be
indian national and not indian nation
i'll just
mention it as national will run it again
okay
now we have
removed these four columns
let me show you the data set now
there you go
so we have only the date column state or
union territory cured that's and
confirmed
now
let's see how you can change the format
of the
date column for that you have the
function called to datetime
i'll say
kovid underscore df
i'll pass in my column name that is date
i'll say equal to
pd dot
i'll use the pandas function that is to
underscore
date time
i'll say covet underscore df which is my
data frame name
pass in my
variable which is date
give a comma
and i'll use my argument that is format
equal to
i'll say percentage y
give a dash say percentage
m
give another dash and say percentage d
let's run it
and i'll print
the head of the data frame cool
now moving ahead
now we will see how to
find the total number of active cases
so active case is nothing but the total
number of confirmed cases minus the sum
of
cure cases plus that's reported
so let's
find the active cases i'll give a
comment
okay i'll first write my
data frame name that is coveted
underscore df
within square brackets i'll give my new
column which is active underscore
cases
i'll say equal to
covet underscore df
and my first column would be
the confirmed cases column
minus
i'll say
kuvid underscore df
then i'll pass in my cured column
plus
i'll again
say
kovid
underscore df
and
add my
deaths column
this time let's print
the last
five rows from the new
data frame that we have created
okay
let's run it
it has thrown an error let's debug it
says
data frame object has no attribute tails
this should be
teal
the hugo
you can see here we have added a new
column called active cases which is
the confirmed cases minus the sum of
cured and
deaths reported column
now we will
learn how to create a pivot table using
the pandas
library
so in this table we'll be summing all
the confirmed deaths and cured
cases
for each of the states and union
territories
so we'll be using the pivot underscore
table function for this
create a variable called statewise
and say pd dot
i'll use the pivot underscore table
function
i'll pass in my
data frame that is covet underscore df
and then
i'll give my
values parameter
inside the square brackets i'll pass in
my
columns
confirmed
deaths
and then we'll have the
cure column
give a comma
and next
argument would be index
which is going to be my state
slash
the union territory column
let me bring this to the next line so it
is more readable
i'll say union territory
i will
give a comma now
and pass in my last argument which is
agg
function that means aggregate function
and
this function would be max
all right
let's run it
okay
now
i'm going to find out the
recovery rate
so recovery rate is basically
the total number of qr cases divided by
the total number of confirmed cases into
hundred
so i'll say
statewise
and within
square brackets i'll
pass in my
variable that i want to create which is
recovery rate
this will be equal to
the
cured cases
multiplied by 100
by the total number of
confirmed cases
within square brackets i'll give my
column as confirmed
let's run this
okay
i'll just copy this column
paste it here so this time we are going
to find out the mortality rate
so mortality rate is nothing but the
total number of deaths
divided by the total number of confirmed
cases into 100
so i'm just going to
replace the
names here i'll say
mortality
all right
and then instead of cured i'll say
my deaths column
into hundred divided by the confirmed
cases let's run it
okay
now
we are going to
sort the values
based on the confirmed cases column
and we'll sort it in descending order so
let me show you how to do it i'll say
statewise equal to
i'll use the function short underscore
values
so i'll pass in my variable statewise
dot and use the
short underscore
values function i'll say by
i want to sort it by my confirmed
cases column
give a comma and i'll say
ascending
equal to
false
let's run it
now we are going to plot our pivot table
using a nice
visual so for that i'm going to use
my
background underscore gradient function
and inside that function we'll pass in
our cmap parameter
i'll show you how to do it
style dot
background
underscore
gradient
and inside this we'll pass in a
parameter called cmap
so cmap stands for color maps this is
present inside the matplotlib library so
here you can see there's a nice
documentation on choosing color maps in
matplotlib
this is provided by matplotlib.org
if i scroll down you can see there are
a number of c maps that you can use
purples blues
you have something called reds
there are other things like magma you
have summer autumn spring winter
cool
all these
you can use whichever color map that you
want and here you can see the different
shades
or the gradients
okay
so i am going to use
my color map as cube helix
let me run it and show you the
pivot table
there you go
here you can see we have our pivot table
ready
now as i said in the beginning there are
a few
discrepancies in the data set so here
you can see
there's one called maharashtra and
there's also maharashtra triple star
this you can ignore even if i scroll
down you have madhya pradesh followed by
three asterisks you can ignore this
value as well even for bihar we have
so these have been duplicated
and
here you can see the different
state names and union territories then
on the top you have the confirmed cases
cured cases
the debts reported and the new
columns that we created
these are calculated columns recovery
rate and mortality rate
and we have ordered it in descending
order of confirmed cases so so far
our data says that maharashtra has the
highest number of cases followed by
kerala karnataka tamil nadu
so these are the top
five states which have the highest
number of
confirmed cases
even if you see the mortality rate is
also high for maharashtra
and
if i scroll down
the mortality rate is also high for
uttarakhand if you see here
if i scroll further
your punjab the mortality rate is also
high
all right
so this was our first
visual that we created in the
govi data analysis project
now moving ahead
we'll see the
top 10 states based on the number of
active cases
so we'll start
i'll give a comment top 10
active
cases
states
okay
so
we are going to explore another very
important pandas function in this which
is known as group by
so i'll first
pass in my data frame which is kovid
underscore df
dot followed by the group by function
i'm going to group my data based on
state slash
union territory column
then i'll say
dot
max which is to find the
maximum value from the states
that have
the highest
active cases so i have passed in my
active cases column
and
we're also going to group it
based on the date column
after that
we're going to sort the values so i'll
use my function that is sort underscore
values
i'll say
short by
my column that is
active
cases let me bring this to the next line
underscore
cases
i'll give a comma and say
ascending equal to
false
say dot
and then
reset my index
for that i'll use reset underscore index
function
okay
let's check if everything is fine
i have
missed a square bracket here let me give
another square bracket here
okay
and all this we are going to store
in our
variable called top underscore 10
underscore active
underscore cases
okay
now let me go ahead and
run this cell
okay there is
a syntax error here
now let's run it okay
now i'll create another variable called
fig
here we'll pass in
the plt which is for matplotlib
library
and will give the
figure size
using the
fig size
argument it's equal to and within a
tuple and passing the size let's say 16
comma 9
we'll run it
okay
and
let's give
a title to our plot so here we are going
to create a
bar plot
so
using plt.title we'll pass in the title
let's say top 10 states
with
most
active cases in india
i'll give a comma and pass in the size
of my title
let's say 25
okay you can see we are slowly
being able to
create our graph
the most important thing is to pass in
the
x-axis and the y-axis
i'll say ax which is for axis
to pass in the axis i am going to use
the bar plot function that is present
inside the c-bond library i'll say
sns.bar plot
i'll say data equal to
my
variable which is top underscore 10
underscore
states
this is actually active states
all right
and now
i'm going to use the
ilock
function
and
take the first 10 states so i'm using a
colon and then giving 10 as my value
iloc is for index location
i'll give a comma and say my
y-axis to be
active cases
give another comma and say my x-axis to
be
state
slash
union territory
give another comma
we are going to pass in the line
width
to 2
i'll say line width equal to 2
and will give
an edge color
let's see the edge color is
red
okay
so i have my
axis defined now
let's run it
there's an error here it says stopped in
active states not found
let's go to the top and see the exact
okay so this is
top 10 active cases let me change it to
cases here
now run it
okay the x axis also has a mistake this
should be
state slash union territory
now let me run it
there you go we have
our plot
created but as you can see here the
labels of the
different states and union territories
are overlapping so for that
let me first pass in the
x labels i'll say plt.x
label
and my
x label would be states
then i'll say
plt dot
by label
my y label will have the total
active cases
and finally i'll write plt dot show
before i run it let's collate all the
lines of code that we have written for
our
top 10 states for most active cases in
india into one cell
so what i'll do is i'll just copy this
and we'll keep
adding
in this cell itself
okay
i'll go to the top
next we'll copy
my figure size
and we'll
paste it here
next let's take the
title
and put it here
give us peace
and we are going to copy
this cell
and i'll paste it here
all right
now it's time to run it there you go
you see it here
we have a nice
bar plot ready on the top you can see
the title top 10 states with most active
cases
and you see the edges are in red color
for all the bars
on the x-axis you have the different
state names maharashtra karnataka kerala
you also have andhra pradesh gujarat
west bengal and chhattisgard
so as you can see
maharashtra
has the
highest number of active cases based on
our data followed by karnataka caroline
tamilnadu at second third and fourth
place respectively
and
in the ninth place we have west bengal
in the tenth place we have chattisgarh
on the y-axis you can see the total
active cases
which are
in lakhs
okay now moving ahead now we'll see the
top 10 states based on the total number
of deaths reported
so i'll give a comment
top states
with
highest
debts
okay
so i'll first
create my variable
saying top 10 underscore
deaths
this will be very similar to
what we did here
just that we need to change a few
column names so instead of active cases
we'll be using depths
okay
so i'll start with my data frame that is
covered underscore df
followed by using the
group by function and i want to group my
data
based on
the state slash
union territory column
then i'll choose the max function
and within
double square brackets i'll pass in
my column names deaths and date
let's make it consistent i'll be using
single quotes
okay i'll say dot
i'm gonna
short my
result therefore i'm using the sort
underscore values function
i want to sort it by
deaths column
i'll give another comma and say
ascending equal to false which means i
want to
order my result in
descending order
then i'll say dot reset underscore index
okay
after that i'll give my
figure size i'll say plt dot
figure
and within brackets i'll pass in my
argument which is
fig size
equal to
using a tuple i'll say 18 comma let's
say 5
now let's give a title for that i'll use
the title function which is present in
the matplotlib library
i'll say
top 10 states with
most deaths
and let's give a size to the title 25
now it's time for us to give the access
labels we'll just scroll down
okay so i'll say ax equal to
again this will be a bar plot so i'm
using my c bond library followed by the
bar plot function
my data will be top
underscore 10 underscore deaths
which is this variable
i'll give
my index location iloc
i'm going to choose
12 states the reason being
there are some discrepancies in the data
i'll show you once i plot this result
so in the y-axis we'll have
deaths column
in the x-axis we'll take
state
slash
union territory
okay
i'll give another comma
and say
line width
equal to 2
and will give
an edge color to our
bars like we did here
so i'll say edge color
equal to let's say
black
okay
now
finally we'll give
the x label the y label
so i'll say plt dot x label
x label would be states
my y label
will be
total
death cases
then i'll write plt dot show
now let's run it
there you go
you can see here we have a nice bar plot
on the top we have the title top 10
states with most deaths
now
what i specifically wanted you to
see was these discrepancies in the data
you can see here maharashtra is repeated
twice even
in our data that we collected from kegel
karnataka
spelling has an error you can see here
we have a few
rows of information where karnataka is
spelled as
k e r a a n instead of k e r n a
all right so to
remove
these
two results or to ignore these two
results i had given
my index location till 12 so we have
maharashtra karnataka tamil nadu delhi
then uttar pradesh west bengal kerala
punjab andhra pradesh and chhattisgard
with the states that have the most
number of deaths reported
okay
now we'll create a line plot to see
the
growth or the trend of active cases for
top five states with most number of
confirmed cases so the states are
maharashtra karnataka kerala tamil nadu
and uttar pradesh i can show you
so these are the states with
highest number of active cases
okay
i'll just give a comment saying
growth trend
all right
so for that
we'll start with our
figure size as
plt dot figure
i'll use my parameter fixed size equal
to
12 comma 6
i'll say
my axis as sns dot
this time we are going to create a line
plot
my data would be
the original data frame that is covered
underscore df
and
within square brackets i'll say covet
underscore df
and we are going to pass in the
state or the union
territory column
i'll give
a dot and use the
is in function
so the
states should include
maharashtra
we'll give a comma the next state should
be
karnataka
next
we have
kerala
give another comma
my fourth state is tamil nadu
give a comma
and my fifth state would be
uttar pradesh
all right
so i'll give
a comma here and then say
x equal to
the date column
y
will be
active cases column
and i am going to use another parameter
called hue
which is to
give different colors to the different
states the five states that we are
looking for
so here
will be my
state slash
union territory column
okay
after this
i'll say
ax dot
set title
my title will be top 5
affected states
in india
we'll give a size let's say
16
all right okay this should be size equal
to 16
and
to make sure everything is fine let me
just
move it to the above line
okay
now we'll run it
okay there is some error again
it says
invalid syntax let's see where we went
wrong
let me bring this to the above line
okay this should be covered underscore
df
okay
make sure you
keep these small errors in check
let's try and run it again
all right
if i scroll down
there you go here you can see we have
the top five affected states in india
you see the
different
states here and the colors so
this violet or the purple color is for
maharashtra you can see how the
active cases
searched around
april and may
and then you can see
even for karnataka the active cases
surged very rapidly
around may
and june
then it has decreased luckily
similarly you can see the plots for even
uttar pradesh
as well as for tamil nadu so all the
five states you can see one common trend
that
after
march so around april
the cases started to emerge very rapidly
and
later after july they started dipping
okay
now
we are going to use our second data set
which is related to vaccination
all right
so first and foremost let me go ahead
and
print the data frame for you
so that you know
the data that we are going to use so
this is the data we are going to use
for our next
set of analysis
even this data has a few errors and you
can see there are a lot of missing
values it makes sense because not all
the days you would have
vaccination for people
and
very crucial
error that we are going to deal with is
this
state column here you can see
in the state column we have india in a
few rows so we are going to ignore these
rows
all right
first let's rename
our updated on column to just
vaccine date
so
you can use the
rename function present in the pandas
library to do it so i'll say vaccine
underscore df dot
rename
i'll say columns equal to
within
curly braces
i'll write
updated
on
which is my
original column name
give a colon i want to change this to
vaccine underscore date
i'll give a comma and say in place equal
to true
so it will change
my
column name from updated on to vaccine
underscore date
in the
original data frame
let's run it
now
let me go ahead and print
the first
10 rows
in the data set
you can see here we have successfully
changed
the column name to vaccine underscore
date the rest of the columns remain the
same
all right
now you can
check
the
total number of
columns
rows
the data types and the memory usage
using the
info function
here you can see it
we have total 24 columns
7845 entries
and these are the
columns that are present
and if i scroll further
you see here
sees
the memory usage and here on the right
you can see the
data type
cool
now as you saw
the data has a lot of missing values
let's find the sum of all the missing
values for each column
so i'll say vaccine underscore df dot is
null
and then i'm going to use the sum
function over it
far on it
there you go
so almost
all the columns have
missing values but columns such as
male individuals vaccinated female
individuals vaccinated even for columns
like
the age groups there are a lot of
missing values
now in the next step we are going to
drop a few
missing value columns so i'll say
a new variable called vaccination
i'll give the data frame name vaccine
underscore df and use the drop function
and inside the drop function we are
going to write
columns equal to
i'll pass in the
column names that i want to drop
i'll say
doses
administered
so this is the column that i want to
delete sputnik v doses administered
i'll give a comma
the second column is e e
f i
the next column is
18 to 44
years
within bracket
it has doses
administered
give a comma
i'll say 45 to
60
years
doses
administered
to another comma
the final column that we are going to
drop is
60 plus which is this one 60 plus years
doses
administered
okay
so these are the columns that we want to
drop
and finally i'll give my parameter
access equal to one
okay let me just recheck this
column names first one is sputnik v
doses administer then we have
efi
followed by
18 to 44 years doses administered then
we have 45 to 60 years doses
administered
finally we have 60 plus years
i've added
a s here which was missing and there
should be a space as well
because there's a space here in the
column now let's run it
all right
so we have successfully dropped
the columns that we wanted to drop
now i'll say vaccination dot head
you can see here
we have dropped those columns and we are
left with these columns now
okay
now
we are going to
create a
plot
that is a pie plot to see
the vaccination for male and
female individuals so i'll give a
comment
as male versus
female vaccination
to create this pie plot i am going to
use the plotly library that we had
imported which is this one plotly
okay
so first of all we need to filter out
the
male individuals
from our data frame
i'll say meal equal to
vaccination
meal
and passing in the column
individuals
vaccinated
we need to recheck the variable name
whether it is correct or not
you see here
male individuals vaccinated
then i'll say
dot
sum
similarly we'll filter out the female
individuals
i'll say female equal to
vaccination
which is my new data frame
within square brackets i'll pass in the
column name female
individual
vaccinated
i'll say dot sum
okay
okay these should be individuals as per
the
column name present in the data frame
cool now i am going to say px
dot pi function which is present in the
plotly library
i am going to
give the names of the
pies
so first one is meal
and the second one is
female
give a comma and say
values
equal to
male comma
female
then i'll give a comma and pass in my
title which is
meal and
female vaccination
okay
this should be names
all right now let's go ahead and run
this cell
it will take some time to create the
pie chart here we go
see here i have my title male and female
vaccination
so these are the two
pies or the areas
you have the label female and the value
here you have the label meal and the
value
so from our data you can see 53 percent
male
individuals have been vaccinated
compared to 47 percent for females
okay
now we are going to drop all those rows
where
our state was mentioned as india in the
original data set
i had shown this to you in the beginning
so we are going to remove
rows
where
state is india
okay
so to do that i'll say
vaccine i'm creating another variable
called vaccine
and
we'll use our original data frame that
we had imported
which is vaccine underscore df
i'll say
vaccine underscore
df
dot
state
not equal to
india
now let's
print vaccine
okay you can see here we have our
data frame printed and from this data
frame we are taking only those values
or the rows where state is not equal to
india
cool
now what we are going to do is
we'll rename the last column which is
total individuals vaccinated to
just total
so i'll say vaccine dot
rename
we'll use the parameter columns equal to
within
curly braces i'll say
total
individuals
vaccinated
give a colon
and we'll change this to just total
give a comma and say in place equal to
true
and finally i'll print my
head of the new data frame
this should be columns equal to
okay
now you can see here if i scroll to the
right and if i check
we have successfully renamed our column
all right
now moving on to the last two
visualizations that we'll see in this
first project using python that is to
find the states with most number of
vaccinated individuals and the state
with the least number of vaccinated
individuals
okay
just give a comment
most
vaccinated
state
okay
for this i'll first create a variable
called wax underscore
vac which is for maximum vaccination
i'm going to use my
data frame vaccine
followed by the group by function
i want to grip it by state column
and
we'll find the total sum
of vaccinated individuals
for each state
i'll convert this to frame
there should be a dot
to underscore frame
and i'll pass in my column name which is
total
after that
i'll say max underscore vac
equal to
max underscore vac dot
short
underscore values
i'm going to sort it by my total column
and say ascending equal to false which
means i want to sort it in descending
order
so that we have the
states with the
highest number of
individuals vaccinated
i want the top five states
now
let's go ahead and
print it
so this will create a nice table for us
there you go
here you can see
we have maharashtra uttar pradesh
rajasthan gujarat in west bengal as the
top five states with most number of
vaccinated individuals
now we are going to use this table and
convert it into a
chart
now i had already written my
code for the
bar plot i am just going to paste it
so here i have defined my
figure size as 10 comma 5
then i'm giving a title as top five
accented states in india and the size is
20
after that i've created a variable
called x
which is going to store my bar plot
this bar plot we have created using the
c bond library
and
you see here i have my
y axis defined
then i have the line width and the edge
color as well
i have given my x label as states by
label as vaccination and i'm finally
going to display my plot so let's go
ahead and run it
okay you can see it here
we have converted this
table into a bar plot now
so first we have maharashtra with the
highest
number of vaccination
then we have uttar pradesh rajasthan
gujarat and west bengal
now
i want
the viewers
watching this video to
find the states with least number of
vaccinated individuals and convert that
table into a
bar plot that will show the
bottom five vaccinated states in india
which means the states which have
least number of individuals vaccinated
so please go ahead and put your
codes in the comment section of the
video it will be very similar to these
two cells just that now we want to know
the least five vaccinated states in
india
so please put the code snippets in the
comments section of this video we'll be
more than happy to know from you in case
you are not able to do it we'll
definitely keep the answers in the
comments itself
all right
so this brings us to the end of the
first project on covet data analysis
using python
so
in this project we used two data sets
one was on
the coveted 19
india data set for different states and
union territories and the second data
set that we used was for
analyzing the status of vaccination in
the different states in india
now we'll move on to our second project
okay so before moving on to our tableau
project let's see the final quiz which
of the following is not a common
coronavirus symptom so this question is
to make you aware of the correct coveted
symptoms
here are the options
is it a fever
b
vision loss c loss of taste and smell or
is it d curve
please put your answers in the comments
section of the video and let us know
what you think
now we will move on to our second covet
data analysis project for this project
we'll be using the tableau software
and a global coronavirus data set
first we look at the data set and the
fields we have
okay so i am in my data set folder
we have already seen the first two data
sets in our python project
this time we are going to use the global
covet data let me open it
all right so here you can see
we have the different country names
there are
192 countries in our data set
let me go to the top
so
we have
country or region
we also have the code
for each of the countries
then we have column called last updated
so here you can see our data is still
12th of march 2021
and there are two columns which
don't have any information that is
people hospitalized and people
tested
then we have a column called
active cases then we have a column for
confirmed cases
in the different
countries we have the number of deaths
and then we have the incident rate
the latitude and the longitude for the
countries
then we have the mortality rate
this is in fractions
then we have the number of
recovered cases and finally we have a
column called uid
so we'll be mostly using the country
column
active
confirmed deaths
and the recovered cases column
and we'll be using the tableau software
to create interesting visualizations and
we'll convert those visuals and put it
in the form of a dashboard
towards the end of the project
okay so let me
close this file or let it be open
i'll search for tableau public
you can see here i have
tableau public installed
you can use the
desktop version of tableau or the public
version of tableau
so for this project we are going to use
the tableau
public edition
so here you can see i have
created a few visuals already
if you want you can clear them out
okay
now
the first thing we need to do is to
connect our csv data set to tableau for
that
under connect
we have to a file i'm going to use
text file
and under
chrome downloads so i'll search for my
folder
kovid
dash india
and here i have my
global covet data file let me open it
this will take some time to load
there you can see
so on the tableau you can see the view
here
it shows the country or the region
you have the last update
you have columns like active confirmed
deaths
mortality rate and recovered
and here you can see the
symbols for the
different columns so this is
a globe which means this field
is a
region or a
geographic field
abc means it's a text field then we have
the calendar which is for a date field
abc our
text field and this
hash represents
numeric fields
all right
so now that we have loaded our data
let me just click on sheet1
so this is the canvas where we are going
to
create our different
reports
all right
so on the left you can see there are two
panes the data pane and the analytics
pane
in the data pane you can see the
name of the data set global covet data
and here you can see the
different columns that we have in the
data set so on the top
the ones marked in
blue are called as dimensions
and at the bottom
whatever you see
are marked in green and are called as
measures
so
dimensions are always represented with
blue icons and measures are in green
icons
so
tableau has automatically detected the
different data types for each of the
columns
all right
so
first of all we are going to create a
simple table
to see the total number of confirmed
cases for each of the
countries
so for that i am going to drag my
country or the region column onto rows
here you have rows i will just drag it
and drop it here
there you go it has populated all my
country names starting from afghanistan
till
jimbah way so it has ordered in
ascending order of alphabets
now to
see the total confirmed cases for each
country i am going to drag my confirmed
column onto text so here under marks
card you have
the text option i'll just drag it
and drop it here
there you go
so tableau how easily has
shown me a table where you can see the
different country names and on the right
you have the total number of cases that
have emerged
from these countries
now this is not the most recent data as
i told you this data was till march 2021
cool
now you can go ahead and
short the
table based on the
total confirmed cases here on the top
you can see here
there are two options to sort in
ascending order or in descending order
let's first sort in
ascending order
by sum of confirmed cases within country
and region
there you go so here you can see
these are the countries which have very
few cases
and if i scroll down
you have france uk russia brazil india
and u.s with the highest number of
kovite 19 cases
if you want you can also
short it in
descending order so that the countries
with the highest number of confirmed
cases appear at the top
you can see it here
and these are the countries that have
very few covet cases
now you can convert this simple table
into different charts and graphs
to do that
here on the
right top corner you have an option
called show me
now
i can just click on
this horizontal bar graph
so that will automatically convert my
table into a bar graph
again you can go ahead and
short the data
there you go
so here you have u.s india brazil russia
uk france spain and italy this is a
horizontal bar graph
sorted in
descending order of confirmed cases
now suppose you want to display only the
top few countries with the highest
number of confirmed cases for that you
can select these bars
so i'll select till let's say
germany
or let's say till argentina
okay and i'll click on keep only you can
see it here it says 12 items selected
that is the sum of confirmed cases i'll
just click on keep only
there you go
so
this horizontal bar graph has
information only for these
few countries that have the highest
number of confirmed cases
now you can go ahead and
play with the color formatting
so here under colors let me choose
a green color
okay
now you can mark here since we selected
only the top 12 countries with the
highest number of confirmed cases so
what we did was we just filtered it to
the top 12 countries so tableau has
automatically added country region in
the filters card
now if you want you can go ahead and
edit this filter as well
suppose you want to remove argentina you
can just uncheck this click on apply and
ok you see here argentina has been
removed
i click on
undo so ctrl z to get it back cool
now you can convert this
horizontal bar plot into a vertical bar
plot let me show you how to do it i'll
just remove these fields from my
chart
now what i'm going to do is i'll
drag country or region onto columns
and i'll have
confirmed
column under rows
there you go here you can see we have
a vertical bar plot now
and again you can
use the axis now to short your data this
is in
descending order similarly you can sort
it in ascending order here you have the
option to
sort your data
okay
cool
and below you can see the
different country names
all right
now you can go ahead and
give
a name to this sheet
let's say
top 10
confirmed
countries
to supply
and click on ok you have the title to
this plot
similarly you can change it here as well
top 10
confirmed
countries
okay
now let's move on to our second
visualization where we will create a
global map so this global map will show
the different countries
present
in the map and the cases that they have
so to create the map first i'll drag my
longitude
generated
field onto columns and then i'll drag
latitude on to rows
you see here we have the map ready
and now
i'll drag
country region onto detail
so this will give you
the different country names you can see
here we have canada
the united states
mexico
here you have india
sri lanka
there's australia
this is brazil
and similarly we have spain france
belgium
there is
italy here we have also greece
similarly we have the african countries
like
central african republic this congo
angola
and on the top you have russia and this
is iceland so on and so forth
now
i'm going to drag
the
active cases column onto
detail again
now if i hover the cursor you can see
the
active numbers for brazil you can see
for india
you have countries like china
then here you have thailand
algeria
now
i'm going to drag the confirmed cases
column on to label so that you have the
labels here you can see here the
confirmed labels
cool
now if you only want to focus on a few
countries
present in a particular region you can
highlight that region for example
suppose
for europe you want to focus on this
region if you select it it will
highlight only those countries and if
you hover your mouse over these points
it will show you the active cases and
the total number of confirmed
cases all right now if you want you can
go ahead and change the color of the
circles let's see i'll keep it as
red
okay
so this is how you can create a
map to represent the different active
and
confirmed cases
i'll rename the title to
global
cases
i just click on apply and okay
similarly i'll change the sheet name as
well to
global cases
okay
now from this map you can see the
countries such as usa
brazil
you have russia
and india with the
highest number of kovit 19 cases even in
countries such as
spain the numbers are
really high
and
a lot of the african countries were also
impacted
and these small countries like solomon
islands you have
fizzy islands with few number of cases
even for new zealand as well
alright
now moving to our next
visual
now we are going to see the top 10
countries where highest deaths have been
reported so far due to the pandemic for
this we will create a tree map now
so first of all i'll
choose my country column and
put it under
columns
and then i'll select
the depths column and put it under rows
i have the
bar plot ready
next i'll go to show me and here i have
the option to select a tree map you see
here for a tree map you need one or more
dimensions and one or two measures so
i'll just click on this tree map
okay here you can see i have my tree map
ready so tableau has automatically
adjusted my fields so it has removed my
fields from rows and columns and put it
under size color and
label
next i will drag my
country column and put it under filters
and from here
i am going to choose top
i'll filter by field i am going to
select the top 10
countries
based on the total number of
deaths
just click on apply and click on ok
so
these are the countries us brazil mexico
india united kingdom italy russia spain
france
germany
which have the highest number of debts
reported
now
you can also
give the label
i'll
put the debts column under label so that
you have the labels here
all right so this was a tree map that we
created to show the
top 10 countries with the highest
number of deaths
i'll just
change the title top 10
deaths
cases
now you can also edit the title in terms
of the font color and everything
that's i'll keep it taboo bold
and i'll choose this as 14 click on
apply and ok
there you go
similarly let's
rename the sheet to
death cases
cool
now moving
to the next visualization where we'll
see
about the recoveries
so before we move on to
create a visualization for the
top 10 or let's say the bottom 10
countries in terms of recoveries let me
show you how to change the
color of the stream app
so here
by default tableau select the automatic
palette
if you want you can change it to
different
palettes let's see i'll go with
gold purple diverging
click on apply and i'll click on ok
if this is
not looking
that great you can select another one
let's say
red green white diverging
cool
now let's
go to our
fourth visualization which is about
top 10
recoveries
i'll click on apply and ok
first i'll drag my country or the region
column
under
columns
and then i'll take
the recovered column under rows
this time
instead of
sum
we are going to choose
average
okay
and here
i'll select
my packed
bubble chart
after that i am going to drag my country
or region onto colors
and then i'll also
put country under filters
so i'll go to
the top
menu
and i'll filter it by field
i want to show the top 10 countries
based on the average number of
recoveries
if i click on apply and ok
you can see here these are the countries
that have
the highest number of
average recoveries you have india brazil
turkey italy argentina germany colombia
russia poland and mexico
i'll just rename this sheet to
recovery cases
cool
now let's move on to our next visual
okay
so here we are going to create a scatter
plot to analyze the total confirmed
cases versus the total number of deaths
so whenever you have two numeric fields
it is better to create a scatter plot to
visualize the
cases
so for that i am going to
drag my confirmed
cases to columns and then i will drag
my
depth column onto rows
okay
so by default
the shape is a circle
and
to see all the countries i'm going to
drag country under color
i'll say add all members
there you go here
you can see the legend
for the different
countries
and
the top you have
us with the highest number of confirmed
cases and the highest number of
deaths as per our data set
then you also have brazil here which has
the
second highest number of deaths
then you have
mexico
followed by india
so this data is not a very recent data
this data was last updated on
march
now from this we are going to filter out
the top 10 countries with the highest
number of confirmed cases
and the deaths
so for that i'll drag my country column
onto filters
and i'll go to top
filter by field
i'll say top 10 and i'll click on apply
and ok
so here you can see we have siberia
sweden
belgium
netherlands
spain
italy france russia
uk and
you have brazil
so these are the countries which have
the
highest number of
active cases
so instead of active let's select deaths
click on apply and okay
okay
now if you see we have us here
brazil india
then mexico
uk
russia france
italy germany and spain which have the
highest number of deaths reported so far
now if you want you can
change
the
size of the circles based on the
highest number of active cases so i can
just drag my active column under size
so you can see here
spain
france
uk have the highest number of active
cases
now let's say instead of active i'll
just have
my confirmed cases under size
okay
and then
you can also change the shape from
circle to
any other shape let's say square or
this asterix
okay
let's go with the triangle
cool
i'll rename this sheet to
confirmed versus
deaths
click on apply and ok
i'll rename this to
confirmed
versus
deaths
all right
now moving on to our
next visualization where we will see
the mortality
for each of the countries
and figure out which countries have the
highest
mortality rate
okay
so
first i'll drag
mortality rate
onto
column
and then i'll have
my
country column under rows
so there you go
now let me go ahead and
sort it in
descending order
so you can see here you have yemen there
is mexico syria sudan egypt equator
china and other countries which have the
highest mortality rate
and you can also
select the country region under colors
let's go ahead and edit the
color
instead of automatic let's select summer
or
you can go for some other palette let's
say
tableau
classic medium i'll assign this palette
yes i'll apply and okay
all right
finally
we'll
move ahead to
our last visualization where we'll
create a dual access chart
so the dual axis chart in tableau will
have one column and two different
visualizations on the rows so here you
have
one column and on the right also you
will have one column with their own
access values
so this dual axis chart will be for
recovered cases and the
death cases let me show you how to do it
so i'll drag
my country
field onto
columns
and then
i'll choose
recovered column onto
rows so here i have got my
line chart
and the second
column i'm going to choose is the depth
column
i'll hold my
cursor and i'll place it
when i get this
green color rectangle i'll place it here
there you go
so now we have created two measure names
death sand
recovered and here you have the access
values
you can synchronize the access values if
you want
the recovered cases are in millions and
the debts are in thousands
now let's go ahead and
change
the
recovered line to
bars
and
we're going to short it
okay
now let's change the color
we'll select let's say
blue
i'll assign the palette click on apply
and okay
and if you want you can also change the
color
for
depths from blue to let's say
winter i'll assign the palette click on
apply and okay
you can have whichever color you want
and to make the access seam you can just
right click on this axis and click on
synchronize access
so here you can see the values
let's keep it in thousands only
cool
i'll rename this sheet to
dual access
okay
now before we move ahead and create our
final dashboard i want to show you
one more
feature in tableau that is to format the
labels so you can see here
instead of writing 5 lakh 30 821 we can
change this in terms of millions or
thousands and write it as let's say 530k
to do that
what i'll do is i'll go to format and
here we have the option
to
select font
and in font i'll go to fields and
click on sum of depths
and here
in this pane
i'll choose
number custom
decimal places will be 0
and
display units i'll select
thousands
you can see here the values have been
changed to 531k 193k 158k
so on and so forth
cool
now let's go ahead and create our final
dashboard here is the option to create a
new dashboard so i'll just click on
new dashboard
and we are going to increase the
size here so that
it fits our
view
so we have selected the default view and
the size i am going to
choose here is automatic so now we can
drop our sheets one by one
first let's drag the
global cases
sheet here
okay you can see we have our map
now
i'm going to choose the top 10 confirmed
cases
all right
and after that we'll choose the
death cases sheet so tableau will prompt
you to place the sheet
at the right location
okay
and now
i'll choose my
fifth visual which is confirmed versus
deaths
and if you want you can choose any one
of
these let's say i'll take the dual axis
chart
now you can just
minimize the
sheets and adjust the
sizes to
make it look better
okay
so you can see here we have our
dashboard ready now you can still go
ahead and customize the dashboards in
terms of adding different
filters to it we are not going to
show that
now you are getting some messages here
two are known for nulls you
can
remove them as well
and here on the top you have the option
to
click on the presentation mode
there you go so this is our final
dashboard that we have created
all right so this brings us to the end
of the
second
coronavirus data analysis project using
tableau
now you can just click on escape to go
back
all right now you can save this
and
this will be published in the
tableau public
platform under your profile
so that brings us to the end of this
video tutorial on kovi data analysis
project using python and tableau welcome
to this exciting video on olympics data
set analysis using python by simply loan
this is going to be a very interesting
and interactive session where i'll give
you a brief about the history of
olympics and throw some light into the
recently held tokyo olympics
but we'll focus more on using olympics
dataset that is available on kegel and
perform some exploratory data analysis
you will understand how to use different
functions in python to analyze and
extract meaningful information during
the course of our discussion i'll be
asking you a few general questions
related to the olympics try to answer
them in the comment section of the video
so let's begin
the olympics is one of the biggest
sporting events on the planet it is held
every four years
the first modern olympics took place in
athens greece in 1896.
as per national geographic
the original olympics took place in 776
bc
so they began as part of an ancient
greek festival with celebrated jews the
greek god of sky and weather
the rings in the olympics logo represent
the five continents europe africa asia
the americas and ushenia from 1924 to
1992 the winter and the summer olympics
took place in the same year but now they
alternate every two years
before i move on here is an interesting
question for you
only two people have ever won gold
medals at both the summer and the winter
olympics
who are those two people
please share your answers in the
comments section of the video we would
like to know from you
the summer olympics in tokyo began on
the 23rd of july and recently concluded
on the 8th of august
we got to witness some thriller matches
that went down to the wire some amazing
victories and sadly there were a lot of
heartbreaks as well
winning and losing are part and parcel
of any game
fans across the world were really happy
to see this global event happen this
year following last year's postponement
due to the coronavirus pandemic
with our olympic fever high let's take
this opportunity to work around a
project to perform exploratory data
analysis using python to analyze and
visualize past olympics data and answer
specific questions
in this video we will be using specific
python libraries such as numpy pandas
matplotlib and c bond to make sense of
our data and extract meaningful
information
we are going to visualize our results
with different charts and graphs
before i show you the data set that we
are going to use for our analysis
i have another general question for you
which is the first olympics where all
the participating countries sent female
athletes a repeat which is the first
olympics where all the participating
countries sent female athletes
put the year and the city name where the
olympics was held in the comment section
of the video
we'll be more than happy to hear from
you
now let me go ahead and show you the
data sets that we'll be using in this
video
so here you can see i have my
olympics data set folder that has two
data sets these are csv files one is
called the athlete underscore events and
the other one is called noc underscore
regions
so
we'll be using these two data sets these
data sets can be downloaded from kegel
we will post the data set links in the
description of the video please go ahead
and download them these data sets have
been directly taken from the internet
now i'll show you the data sets
so this is my first data set you can see
on the top athlete underscore events
so i have
around
15 columns you can see the count here
and there are
nearly
2 lakh 71 116 rows of information
so this is a huge data set that we are
going to use
the other data set we are going
to use in this demo is called noc
underscore regions now here one thing to
note is
noc stands for national olympic
committee this is a three letter code
that is given by the olympic committee
we have the region name so afg is for
afghanistan you have alb for albania elg
for algeria we have also a column called
nodes you find some
notes about the
region for example here antiqua is
actually antiqua and
barbuda
all right
let's move to the
first data set that i showed you
this is our primary data set for our
demo
so these data sets have been directly
taken from the internet and were not
validated so the results that you will
see in the demo is purely based on the
data that we have collected
so the file athlete underscore
events.csv contains
nearly 2 lakh 71 116 rows of information
and there are 15 columns
so each row corresponds to an individual
athlete competing in an individual
olympic event
so here id is actually a unique number
for each athlete then we have the name
which is basically the athlete's name we
have the sex or the gender which is male
or f for female
then we have the age of the athlete
which is in terms of integers
we have the height in
centimeters of the athletes then we have
the weight in kilograms we have the team
name these are the country names you
have china denmark netherland there are
around 200 country names
then we have the noc as i said noc
is a three letter code that stands for
national
olympic committee
we have the games this games contains
the year and the season you can see here
1992 summer you also have the winter
olympic information
all right
then we have a specific year column
to
tell you in which year this event had
occurred
now the year column is also an integer
column
we have the season so whether it was
summer olympics or winter olympics
then we have the city name this is the
host city
then we have the sport name you can see
here we have basketball judo football
tug of war
speed skating
there are so many
then we have another column called event
which is the complete even name as you
can see the sport name is basketball but
the even name is basketball men's
basketball to be very specific
again for speed skating you have
different categories like women's 1000
meters 500 meters
all right
now the final column is the middle
column so it has
the information about the athlete
whether
the athlete had won a medal bait gold
silver branch and na means the athlete
did not win any medals so we'll use
these two data sets
now let's
get started with the demo
we'll be using jupyter notebook for our
analysis so i'll take you to my jupyter
notebook right away
i've opened it on chrome so this is my
jupyter notebook that we are going to
use you can see here olympics data set
analysis
i have already
have a few cells that have been filled
with some piece of code
and you can see there are
some comments written as well we are
going to use this data set
so let's get started
first and foremost we'll import the data
sets so we are going to use
numpy pandas matplotlib and c bond
let me hit shift enter to import all the
libraries
all right
now the next thing is to load the
datasets
using
pandas read underscore csv function
so
i'll create a variable called athletes
i'll say equal to
pd dot i'll use the read underscore csv
function
and inside this function will give the
location
of the files so i'll copy this location
and here i'll paste
make sure this is within
quotations
and these are all
forward slash
i'll give another forward slash
and after that i'll give the
file name that is
athlete
underscore
evens
dot csv
i'll close the quotation
let's run it
okay similarly we will load the second
data set i'll create another variable
called regions
so it will have my data frame
i'll use the same function pd dot read
underscore csv
i'll just copy this
file path
till here
we'll paste it
and
i'll give my second file name which is
noc
underscore
regions
dot csv
you can verify here
the first one is athlete underscore
events the second one is noc underscore
regions
okay i'll close the quotation and we'll
run it again
okay there seems to be some error i
think this is the regions
cool
now moving ahead
let's see the
first few rows of both the data sets
i'll use the head function for that
i'll say
athletes dot head
so this will print the first five rows
from my data set
athletes you can see here
from zero to four you have five rows of
information the id name sex or the
gender
each height weight
if i go to the right you have games
year season sport event and middle
now let's see
the
second data set that we
imported or loaded
i'll say regions dot head
it says
regions
is not defined
let me cross check it
okay i have taken it as region let's
make it regions
cool
now let's run it there you go so these
are the first five rows from our second
data set you have noc region and some
nodes
all right
now the next step is to combine
both the data sets so we'll join the
data frames using the pandas merge
function
let me show you how to do it
so this is going to be a horizontal join
i'll create a variable
called athletes underscore df
then
i'll use my first
variable which is athletes
i'll say dot merge which is my function
name
i'm going to merge
the regions data frame
i'll use the how parameter
in how i'll give my value as
i want to do a left join
and my common column in both the data
sets is actually noc
so i'm going to use the noc column as my
common column to merge both the data
sets
now let's go ahead and
print the
most data frame i'll say athletes
underscore df.head
let's run it
there you go
so
if you see clearly if i move to the
right you can see here we have added two
more columns that were present in the
second data set which was regions so we
have regions and nodes
added to my
first data set that is
athletes underscore
events
cool
now one thing to note here is
see the column names are not consistent
if you see here the rest of the columns
start with a capital letter but if you
see the last two columns that we just
added now start with a lowercase letter
so we'll use
the rename
function to
make the column names consistent
but before that
let's
see the
shape of the data frame so i'll print
the shape of the data frame to know the
total number of rows and columns
i'll say
athletes if i hit tab
you will see it will give me
the prompt i'll select athletes
underscore df
i'll use the
shape attribute
let's run it
and see the result you can see here it
gives me the total number of rows so 2
lakh 71 116 rows and earlier we had
15 columns in the first data set and now
that we have added two more columns so
the total number of columns becomes
17 now
cool
so now it's time to make the
column names consistent
so i'll show you how to do it i'll say
athletes underscore
df
dot i'll use the rename function
and then
i'll say
columns
equal to
i'll use curly braces
my first column that is a region i want
to change it to
a region but the r should be capital now
or uppercase
will give a comma
and then see
my second column
this should be
a region actually
my second column that is notes
i want to
change the first letter to uppercase so
i'll say capital n
the rest all remains same
i'll give a comma here
and say
in place equal to true
so it will change
the column names and will reflect
in this athletes underscore df data
frame
let's run it
now to verify you can again use the head
function i'll run this again let me
scroll down and move to the right you
can see the difference there you go so
we have successfully renamed the last
two columns region and notes
all right
now moving ahead
now
i'll show you how you can use the info
method to print information about a data
frame including the index data type the
column data types
normal values and memory usage so for
that you just need to use the info
function so i'll write
athletes underscore df
dot info
let's run it there you go so here we
have the
data columns you can see total
17 columns you have two lags
7116 rows or entries
then you have the
different column names and
you see it says non-null and the data
type of the column
below you can see some information about
the memory usage
all right
next
the describe method is used for
calculating statistical information such
as mean standard deviation the
percentiles of the numerical values of
the data frame and much more
it analyzes both numeric and object
series and also the data frame column
sets of mixed data types
so let me show you how using
the describe function you can display
some statistical summary
i'll just write
describe
and
give parenthesis let's run it
okay if i scroll down
you can see here
by default
the describe function will only give
information about numerical columns
so here you can see we have the total
count the mean of each of these columns
you have the standard deviation the
minimum and maximum value and then we
have the 25th percentile the 50th
percentile and the 75th percentile value
of
the columns id age height weight and
year
all right
now one thing to notice here is if you
see the year column
the minimum year is 1896
so this is when
olympics started
and until recently
the rio olympics that was held in 2016.
all right
now moving ahead
now let's check if there are any null
values present in the columns of the
data set
so first i am going to create
a variable called
nan values
give equal to i'll see
athletes underscore df
and the function to check is i'll say is
n a
i'll create another
variable called nan underscore
columns
and here i'll use the any function i'll
say nan underscore
this
variable which is underscore values
dot i'll see any
and i'll print
my nan columns variable
so this will display the result in terms
of
boolean values so if there are any null
or nan or missing values in any of the
columns it will say true otherwise it
will say false
let's display the result
there you go
so if you mark here clearly
so there are
nearly six columns where we have missing
values you have
age height wheat metal region and notes
columns that have
missing values so hence
it has given us true the rest of the
columns do not have any any n or missing
values hence they are false
all right
let me scroll down
now
let's see the total number of null
values for the
above
six columns
so i'll say
athletes
underscore df
dot
i'll use the function is null
and again i'll use this sum function
okay this should be is null
if i run it
you can see it here
so our age column has
9474
rows where we have null values
then we have
some null values for the height column
as well for the weight column so these
are the total number of
rows where we don't have
any information regarding each height
weight or region
notes this medal is
self-explanatory because a lot of the
athletes who participate in olympics
don't win any medals so for them
the value is any now before i move ahead
i have a question for
you people so the question is i want you
to print the column names containing
null values or missing values in the
form of a list
so
please answer this question and put it
in the comments section of the video we
would be happy to
know your approach
so the question i'll repeat it again i
want you people to print the column
names containing null values or missing
values in the form of a list so
basically
on the top we saw there were
six columns that had
null values i want you to print these
six
columns in the form of a list all right
now moving ahead
now let's see the data for specific
countries
let's say you want to see the athletes
who have participated in the olympic
games from the beginning for india
for that you can filter your result
using a function called query
so let me show you how to do it i'll say
athletes
underscore df
dot
we'll use the query function
and then
i'll say
team
which is my column name
should be equal to equal to
and the value i'll give is india
now let's
display the first five
rows of information
or the details for the athletes who are
from india if i run this
okay there is some error here
okay so we need to make sure this entire
expression or the condition should be
within
single quote i'll just
delete this single quote from here and
we'll add it in the end now let's
run it the yuko
so here you can see we have
the top five rows
of
the athletes who are from india you can
see here the region is india you can see
the noc is india the team is india
and
let me go to the left you can see the
name of the athlete
the sex each
so for each you have some missing values
you have to wait
team year and everything
all right
similarly you can also check for
japan let me just copy the
above
code i'll paste it here
and instead of india i'll say
japan
i'll run it
there you go
so if you see here
you can see all the details are for the
athletes who are from japan
all right
moving ahead now i want to know the top
10 countries who have participated since
the inception of olympics in
1896
so for that i'll create a variable
called top underscore 10 underscore
countries
let's say equal to
i'll use my data frame that is
athletes underscore
df
i'll say dot
team
then i'll use the function
value underscore
i am going to
sort
my count
in ascending order
just mark the way in which i am writing
the functions
any error in terms of syntax or the flow
will
throw you an error
i want to display the top 10 countries
now let's go ahead and
print it i'll say
top underscore 10 underscore countries
all right
let me run it
okay it has given us an error let's
debug it okay so this should be
value
counts and not count
let's run it again
another error
okay
so this should be short underscore
values and not value
let's run it again there you go
so here you can see the top 10 countries
participating in olympics since
1896 you have united states then we have
france so these are the number of
participants who have taken part
since 1896.
so the most number of participants have
come from us then we have france great
britain italy germany canada japan
sweden
we also have australia and hungary
i'll scroll down
now we are going to convert this table
that we got or the output that we got
in the form of a graph
so i'm trying to create a bar plot to
plot the
top ten countries who have participated
in olympics so here i'm using the
figure function to give the figure size
so these are the dimensions 12 comma 6.
now i'll tell you what this plt x6 means
just wait for a while
i have given a
title to my plot saying overall
participation by country
and then
using the c bond library and the bar
plot function
i am plotting the
x
and the
y axis so my x axis has top i should
make this top 10 countries because above
we used top underscore 10 underscore
countries similarly for
y-axis i'll make it top underscore 10
underscore countries and then i'm using
a color palette called set 2
let's run it
there you go so if i scroll down you can
see here we have a nice
bar plot
this is a vertical bar plot
and here you can see the bars which
represent the different country names
first we have united states which has
the highest participation since the
beginning of the olympics then we have
france great britain italy germany
canada
and we have the rest of the countries
cool
now moving ahead
the next visualization we are going to
see is the age distribution of the
athletes
so for this we are going to create a
histogram
i'll be using the matplotlib library
specifically for this visualization
so i'll say plt dot figure
we'll give the figure size using the
argument fig size
equal to
and this will be a tuple actually
my size is going to be 12 comma 6
i'll say
plt
dot
title
now you can give
any title that you want i'll say
each
distribution
of the
athletes
then we'll also give the x labels i'll
say plt dot
x label
this will have each
then we see plt dot
y label
and this will have
the label as number of
participants
next
i'm going to use the hist function so
i'll say plt.test
and i'll
pass in my data frame that is
athletes
underscore df
dot
age
which is my column name
comma
i am going to pass in the
bins
for that i am going to use the np dot
e-range function so mp is for numpy
and inside this i'll say
10 comma
80 comma
2.
so my bins will start from the value 10
and go until 80 with a size of 2.
comma
i'll give another parameter that is
going to specify the color of the bins i
want my color to be
orange
and then
i'll use
the edge color to separate the bins
lch color this is the
parameter or the argument name and the
color i want is white
let's give a
semicolon here and this should be edge
color there's a spelling mistake here
now let's run it and we'll see the
output
so there you go
so this is a nice
histogram that shows the distribution of
the
age of the athletes you can see the
title each distribution of the athletes
on the y-axis you have the number of
participants on the x-axis we have the
age values ranging from
10 to 80 with a size of
2
and if you say this
we have
most number of athletes
who have age between
20 to 30 you can see here
so early 20s we have maximum number of
athletes participating in the olympics
we also have a few athletes who are
beyond 40 years of age you can see here
we have a
few athletes
even closer to 60 also and similarly we
have a few athletes who are
under 18 years of age
all right
now you can see here the bins we had
taken orange color so are all the
bars are represented in orange color
and the edge you can see here we have
the white color
all right
now moving ahead
now in the initial slides of the video
we discussed the summer and winter
olympic games let's look at the
different sporting events that are part
of the summer and winter olympic games
just to give you a heads up the winter
olympic games are held once every four
years for sports practiced on snow and
ice
so here
i have my variable name winter
underscore sports so i am extracting
for season equal to equal to
winter and i am going to display only
the unique values now let me run this
cell
okay so you can see here these are the
different winter sports that are
held
during the winter olympics now similarly
let's see for
summer olympics so what i'm going to do
here is i'll just copy this
cell of code and we'll edit the
variables i'll say summer
underscore sports
athletes underscore df remains the same
here season will change it to
summer
dot sport dot unique remains the same
and
here i'll say summer underscore sports
that should be small
now let's run it
there you go
so here you can see we have
more number of olympic sports that are
held during the summer olympics compared
to
winter olympics
so these are the sports that are played
on snow and ice
and these are the sports that are played
during
summer
moving ahead
now it's time to analyze the total
number of male and female participants
who have taken part in different games
since 1896 till 2016 rio olympics
all right
so i'll say
gender
underscore counts which is my variable
name
i'll use my
data frame that is
athletes underscore df
dot
my variable name that is sex
dot
value underscore
counts
and then we are going to print
gender underscore counts
let's run this
there you go
so since the inception of olympics
we have more number of male participants
than
female
participants now here in this current
cell you
can see we are trying to plot a
pie chart for male and female athletes
so i have given my figure size then i
have my title as gender distribution i'm
using the matplotlib library and the
pi function
i'm using the variable gender counts
that we used here
then i'm giving my labels as gender
underscore counts dot index now i'm
using this auto pct
the auto pct parameter enables you to
display the percent
value using python string formatting so
this is my string formatting that i have
used and i'm
initialized my start angle for the pie
chart as 150 degrees and i am also
giving shadow to my pie chart so i have
written shadow equal to true
let's run it
all right so you can see here this is my
pie chart that shows you the
distribution of the
male and female
participation
so for meal it is 72.5 for female so far
it is
27.5 as per the dataset that we have you
can change this start angle to let's say
180 degree
and it will
change the pie chart to this direction
cool
now moving ahead
this time
we're going to find the total number of
medals that the athletes have won
so i'll use my
data frame athletes underscore df dot
and then my column that is
middle i'll say dot
value
underscore counts
let's run it there you go so you can see
the gold medals the bronze medals and
the silver medals are
very much
similar to each other the numbers are
pretty much the same
all right
now it's time to focus on the total
female athletes who have taken part in
each
olympics
so i'll create a variable
called
female underscore
participants
i'll say equal to and then use my data
frame name that is athletes underscore
df
using
square brackets
i'll say
athletes
underscore df dot
the gender should be equal to equal to
female
and
i'll use ampersand
i'll say
just copy this
paste it here
lc dot
season
equal to equal to we'll check for summer
olympics
and i want to extract only
the gender column so here it is sex
comma
my year column which is here
okay
and then
i'll say
female
underscore
participants
equal to
i'll just copy this
paste it here
and then i'll use the group by function
say group by which is part of the pandas
library
i'll say year
and then i want to find the count
i'll reset the index
say reset underscore
index
is a function
and finally we are going to print
female underscore participants
and let's say the head
all right
so what we are trying to do is i am
trying to filter
my data only for the female athletes for
summer olympics
and here
i am printing
the participation
based on each year so i am finding out
the count
so here we need to
add one more square bracket
all right
now we'll
run it and see the result
the yuko
so you can see here from 1900
1904 all these years you can see the
female participation
let me change it to teal so that we have
the recent data of the
olympics
you can see it here for the beijing
olympics 5816
women athletes participated in 2012
london olympics we had five thousand
eight hundred and fifteen olympics
similarly for the 2016 rio olympics we
had
more participation than the london
olympics so six thousand two hundred and
twenty three
women athletes had participated
all right
now here
this is another way in which you can
filter your data for female athletes so
i'm
using two parameters my gender should be
equal to female and season
is summer olympics let me just run it i
have stored it in a variable called
women olympics
now
here i am trying to
find a
count plot or i am trying to create a
count plot using my seabond sns library
i have set my style to dark grid
then my figure size i have given as
20 comma 10
my count plot will have the x axis
as year
the data is women olympics
and palette i'm using as spectral
and then i have given a title women
participation
let's run and see the output
there you go if i scroll down you can
see on the top i have the title for my
count plot which says
women participation and on the y-axis i
have the count
and at the bottom you can see the
different year values from 1900 till
2016
and 2016 had the highest
number of female participation
cool
let me scroll down so in this cell of
code we are trying to plot a line graph
let me run it and show you the output
so this line graph shows the trend
which says plot for female athletes over
time
so here you can see the line graph so
gradually
the women participation has increased in
olympics
since its inception
there was a slight decrease here this is
around
1950s
and again you can see here there's a
decrease with the women participation in
1980 but since then since 1980 there has
been continuous
increase in the participation of female
athlete numbers
cool now coming to the next section
of our analysis
now we are going to filter the data to
see the details of the athletes who have
won gold medals
so
i'll create a variable called gold
medals
it's equal to i'll use my
data frame as
athletes underscore df
and
within parenthesis i'll use my data
frame name
which is
athletes
underscore
df
dot
i'll use the condition middle equal to
equal to
and my value would be gold
next
i'm going to
say
gold medals dot head
let's run it
there you go
so here
we have the
top five rows of the athletes who have
won
a gold medal you can see
all the
records have medal as gold
now we are going to use this
subset
of the data and perform some more
analysis
so here
i want to take only the values that are
different from nan so i'm going to use
is
finite
function and inside that i have set goal
middles each
let me just run it cool
now i want to see
the athletes who have
secured a gold medal beyond the age of
60 years
which is very rare
so we'll see the total number of
athletes with more than 60 years of each
having won a gold medal
so here i'm going to say
gold medals
use my
column as id
and then
i'll use
my variable
gold medals
and then
i'll say
age
should be
greater than
60
and then
close my square bracket and say count
okay let me just verify if everything's
fine
yeah
i'll run it
and we'll see the result so there are
total
six athletes who have won a gold medal
having aged more than 60 years
cool
now let me
check
for which
sport these six gold medals have come
so i'll say
sporting underscore event
this is going to be my variable name
equal to
i'll use the
same variable name gold medals
i'll going to choose
my sport column
and then
i'll give my
condition
age
greater than 60.
now let's go ahead and
we'll print
the variable spotting event
if i run this you can see it here
so
for art competitions
even for archery and suiting and this
one called rook
we have had gold medals from athletes
who had an age
more than 60 years
now we are going to plot
this result or the table that we
achieved on the top
so i'll say plt dot
figure
i'll give my
figure size
equal to let's say 10 comma 5
then
i'll say plt dot
we'll use the
type layout
say tight underscore
layout
then i'm going to use the c bond library
and
create a count plot
for my variable
sporting underscore
event
then i'll say plt dot
title
i'll give the title as
gold medals
for
athletes
over
60 years of age
let's run it
and if i scroll down you can see here we
have a nice count plot i have my title
gold medals for at least over 60 years
and since
for archery we had
three players who secured a gold medal
having in each more than
60 years
you can see here archery is three at
competition one
rock is one and shooting we had
one medal
all
right now
we'll see the total gold medals
from each country
so for that
i'll say
gold
medals
dot
will use the
region column
and
followed by that i'll use the
value underscore
counts function
and
i'll reset the index
with
name
equal to i'll provide the
middle column
then we are going to print the
head for the top five
countries let me run it you can see it
here
so
usa
has secured the most number of gold
medals then we have russia germany uk
and then we have italy
cool
now in this cell i am going to create a
plot to
visualize the table that i got
above
so i've used my labels my titles i am
using the cat plot function that is
present in the c bond library i have my
x axis my y axis the data which is total
gold medals
let me just verify
okay
and we'll run it
if i scroll down
you can see this is a different palette
that i had used which is rocket
and you can see
usa has got the
most number of gold medals then we have
russia germany uk
italy and france now we also have
included france here which was not
present in this table the reason being i
have used head
as six
so it will give me the top six countries
all right
now we will analyze
and look at the data for the most recent
olympic event that is present in our
data set i'm talking about the 2016 rio
summer olympics
so first of all i'll create a variable
called max year
which will be equal to my data frame
name athletes underscore df
my column name here and i'll use the max
function
then
let's go ahead and print my max here
i'll just show you the output you can
see here my max here present in the data
set is 2016 the rio olympics
next
we will
create another variable called team
underscore names
that will be equal to
my
data frame name athletes underscore df
within square brackets i'll give
parenthesis and then say
athletes underscore df
dot
year
should be
equal to equal to
my
output that is max here
which is actually 2016
and then i'll say
ampersand
i'll just copy this
we'll paste it here
this time i'll use the
middle column and c equal to equal to
gold
i'll say dot
team
then i'll say team
underscore names dot
value
underscore
counts
dot head
and will display the
top
10
countries
let me run this
there you go
so in geo olympics
united states secured the
most number of gold medals
now the reason this is 137 is we have
also counted
the team events for example basketball
similarly great britain had 64 gold
medals in total
russia 50 we have brazil 34 argentina 21
france 20 and japan 17.
all right
now
using the above result we are going to
create a bar plot i'll just change the
steam underscore list to team underscore
names
similarly here also i'll make the
corrections as
team underscore names
cool
now we'll run it
and you can see here we have a nice
horizontal
bar plot so we have united states at the
top
great britain russia germany china
brazil
so here i'm displaying the top
20 nations since i've used head
as 20
so these are the top 20 nations who
secured the
most number of gold medals in the u.
olympics
alright
now in the final section of this video
we will create a scatter plot to
visualize the height and weight of male
and female athletes who have won a medal
now it can be a gold medal a silver
medal or a bronze medal
but before that
we
need to filter the data only for
athletes who have won a medal
now if you
had noticed here our
medals column also had a few
null values so we are not going to
consider
those null values here
we are only going to consider for the
athletes who have
banner medal
so for that i will create a
variable called not underscore null
underscore
medals
equal to i'll say
athletes underscore
df
then
i'll give my
let's make it df
i'll give my condition
let me just copy this
i'll paste it here
and then
i'll give my condition
height
and use the
not
null
function
and then i'll say
ampersand
create another parenthesis i'll say
athletes underscore df
this time we'll consider the
weight column
again i'll use the function as not null
and
i'll close the parenthesis
okay i had missed one s here cool
let me just run it now
all right
now we are going to create our final
plot i'll say plt dot figure
i'll give my
figure size
equal to
i'll say 12 comma 10.
i'll say access
equal to
sns dot
we'll be creating a scatter plot to plot
the
height and weight of the athletes who
have won a medal
i'll say scatter plot
in my x-axis i'll have
height
comma
in my y-axis i'll have weight
comma
my data should be
not
underscore null underscore
medals
so this is what we created here not
underscore null underscore medals
comma
i'll use hue equal to my
sex column
cool
finally i'll say plt dot i'll give a
title to my plot
saying
height
versus
weight
of
olympic
medalists
cool
now let's see our scatter plot
this might take some time to keep the
result because there are so many
athletes present
in a data set who have won a medal and
also we are filtering
in terms of
hue which is for male and female
there you go
so if i scroll down you can see here
we have a nice scatter plot
on the top we have the title of the plot
saying height versus weight of olympic
medallist you can see
our age as the hue
so blue points are for the male athletes
and orange points are for the female
athletes
and on the y-axis we have the weight in
terms of
kilograms and you have the height in
terms of centimeters
cool
so that brings us to the end of this
demo session on
olympics
data set analysis
so we used two data sets to
[Music]
carry out this exploratory data analysis
and we
created some
visualizations to analyze and visualize
the data
all right
so that brings us to the end of this
video tutorial on olympics data set
analysis
indian premier league that is ipl is one
of the most popular and exciting events
in world cricket
ipl 2022 will begin on 26th of march so
it's the best time for us and our
viewers to learn about how to perform
exploratory data analysis using the
recently held ipl auction data set
so in this video all the results and
insights that you will see are totally
based on the data we have collected from
kegel we will leave a link to the data
set in the description of the video you
can go ahead and download it
for this demo we'll be using python and
jupyter notebook to answer special
questions
so let's get started we'll move over to
our jupyter notebook
okay so i'm on my jupyter notebook and
this is the file that we are going to
use so here you can see i have
some of the cells already filled in so
this will save us some time and we can
explore this data set in depth so this
is the file that i'll be using or the
ipython notebook
cool
so first let's go ahead and import all
the crucial libraries that will be
needed for our analysis so here you can
see i am importing the pandas library
the numpy library these are for data
manipulation and numerical computation
then we have cbon and matplotlib for
data visualization
then
i have imported this warnings
module
so that we do not get any warnings while
running the code cool
so let me just hit shift enter to run
the first cell
so here we will import
all the libraries okay it's done
now the next step is i'm going to create
a data frame in the name of ipl
and here i am importing the data set
using the read underscore csb function
which is part of the pandas library so
pd here has been imported as pandas i am
giving the
data set location followed by the name
of the data set so here the name is ipl
underscore 2022 underscore dataset dot
csv is the extension of the file
so let me go ahead and run this as well
all right so now we have
successfully imported or loaded our data
set
now the next step let's go ahead and
explore our
data set so i'll use the head function
for this
ipl dot head
okay so here you can see the different
columns we have
an unnamed column which is actually
unnecessary for our analysis so we'll
see how to drop this column
apart from that we have the name of the
players the base price at which the
player was sold or whether the player
was a draft pick so here rasit khan from
afghanistan hardik pandya then we have
subman gill these are all
draft pick and then we have the
price at which the players were listed
in the ipl auction then we have the
type of player whether the player is a
bowler an all-rounder a batsman
or
a wicket keeper
then we have the cost in rupees this is
in crores so basically this column tells
us the
price at which the player was sold in
the auction
then we have the price or the cost in
dollars
after that we have 2021 squad basically
this means
in last year's ipl where was the player
so here you can see rasat khan was
playing
for srh the sunrises hyderabad in 2021
but this year in 2022 he'll be playing
for gujarat titans similarly hardik
pandya was playing for mumbai indians
for past few seasons including 2021 but
this season is going to play for gujarat
titans
so on and so forth
now
let's see the total number of players
that are present in the data set and the
total columns that are there for this
i'm going to use
the shape attribute so i'll write ipl
dot shape you can see here there are
total 633 players that were part of the
auction and this includes the players
who were draft pick also
and there are total
eight columns in my dataframe ipl
next
let's use the info function to check the
columns the data types and the total
non-null objects so i'll say
ipl dot info which is a function so i
have to use brackets
there you go so here you can see it
saves total 633 entries from 0 to 632
data columns we have total 8 columns and
then these are the
different
column names and
here you can see the total
normal objects
present in the
column
and here you can see the data types
and at the bottom you can see the
memory usage as well
cool
now
the dot columns attribute will return
the name of the columns in the
data set so if i say ipl dot columns and
run it it will give me all the different
column names that are present in the
data frame
now as i said
the first column which is unnamed
colon 0 is
actually unnecessary so we are going to
drop it for that
we are going to use the
dot drop function and then i have passed
in my
column name followed by the axis on
which axis is it there
and then i say in place equal to true
which means it will
replace
and permanently remove
the unnamed column from the data frame
so let's run it and now we'll again
check
the head of the data frame you can see
before we had the
unnamed column which was the first
column in the data frame and now we have
successfully removed it so player
becomes the first column in the data
frame
all right
now moving ahead
let's see the total number of null
values that are present in each column
of the data set so i'll say
ipl dot i'm going to use the is null
function
followed by this sum function
if i run this you can see here
the player column doesn't have any null
values similarly base price and type
column also don't have any null values
but you can see cost and rupees and cost
in dollars have
nearly 396
missing or null values the reason being
those players were not
picked in the
ipl auction and hence there was no price
associated
and then you can see there were a few
players who were not part of the ipl
squad in 2021
so
those are being reflected as null as
well
now we'll check the rows that have
cost in dollar as null or nan so here i
have
used ipl and after that i am passing in
the column name which is cost in dollars
and then i have used the is null
function
if i run this
you can
notice the
cost in
dollars column all these values are nan
or
null and even the same
rows have
nan for cost in rupees as well
cool
now the
next task is to fill these
null values or nan values with
zeros so for that i am going to use the
fill any function and here i have passed
in zero so all the null values in the
data set will be replaced with zero for
cost in
rupees column and
cost in dollars column
let me just run it
all right
okay
now
we will see the players who were unsold
in the 2021 auction which means
uh we will check the rows that have null
values for the 2021 squad column
so what i'll do is i'll say
ipl
within
square brackets i'll say ipl and then
i'll pass in my
column name which is 2021
squad
and then after this i'll say dot
is null
so
this
cell
will give
us the unsold players in the 2021
auction
if i run this
you see here
you mark the 2021 squad column all these
players were unsold or did not
participate so hence
it has any n values
all right
now what we are going to do is
we will replace all the null values
that are present in the
2021 square column with
not participated
like how we did in the previous example
we replaced all the null values with
zero here we'll replace with
a text value called not participated so
i'll say ipl
i'll pass in my column name which is
2021 squad
equal to
i'll say
ipl
2021
squad dot
fill
any
which is the function and here i'll pass
in a
text or a string saying not
participated
all right
let's run it
before that let me just scroll it down
now i'll run it cool
now that we have treated the null value
successfully let's verify it again
so i'll just say ipl
dot
is null
and then i'm going to use this sum
function
if i run this
okay this is also a function cool now if
you see we have successfully removed all
the null values and replaced with either
zeros or not participated and hence now
you can see none of the
columns in the ipl data frame have null
values so it shows zero
great now moving ahead
now we are going to add another column
called
status
which will hold two values sold and
unsold but before that
we are going to
slice
our data frame so here i am looking for
all the rows where
cost in rupees
is greater than
0
and those should be unique and
i am storing the value in a variable
called teams so here you can see we have
the different teams where the
cost in rupees is greater than zero
now
i'm going to create
another
column called status so i have written
ipl
within square brackets i'm passing in
the column name which is status and
that will be equal to
the team
replaced by
soul value
let me just run it and show you the
result there you go
so here you can see we have added a new
column called status and it has values
sold
and unsold
if i just say ipl
at the bottom you can see
the unsold values as well
cool
now in the next cell
we are going to check for duplicated
players so there are duplicate rows in
the data frame but here the names of the
players are same but in reality the
players are different
so
it is quite understood that
different players can have the same name
so
to get those names i am using the
duplicated function and i'll say keep
equal to false which means i don't want
to keep those players
now let's run it
there you go so here you can see
lalitha we have
two entries so lalithyadev here is an
all-rounder
whose base price was 20 lakh
for 2022 ipl
and
last year
he was playing for the delhi capitals
this year also
he is
sold
to delhi capitals
next we have
who happens to be a bowler so this is
again different lalitha
so last year
he was unsold and even this year he
remains unsold
similarly we have amit mishra
who earlier used to play with the delhi
capitals but this time he remains unsold
so on and so forth so you can see two
entries for
shrink as well and shivam mishra
all right
now let's answer a very basic question
we are going to
find out how many players
have participated
in the 2022 ipl auction
for that we have already seen the total
number of rows that were present but
again i am going to use the shape
function and within
square brackets i am going to say 0
which means it will give me the total
number of rows
and you can see
633 players were part of the auction
this is as per our data that we have
collected from kegel
up next we are going to find
how many types of players have
participated
so i'm going to say
types equal to
say ipl
i'll use the column name which is type
and i'm going to find the
count of
each type of players that are present in
the data frame
i am going to use the values underscore
counts function
and then i will say
type
dot
reset underscore index
if i run it
okay there is an error here let me
debug the error
okay so this should be value underscore
counts and
the variable name is types and not type
so let's run it you can see here
we have the different
types of players so all rounders there
are total 242 all rounders are part of
the auction then we have 215 bowlers 112
batsmen's and 64 wicket keepers
now using the above
table that we just created
i am going to
plot my first
pie chart
so for that i'm going to use the
matplotlib pi function so plt.pi i'm
using
types.values since i want
only the values from this table
and then i'm saying labels equal to
types dot
index
i've used a label distance of 1.2 to
maintain some space
and then this is my format in which i
want to
print or show or display the percentage
of
distribution i am going to use shadow so
it says shadow equal to true which is
another parameter or an argument and
then i am going to start my angle at 60
degrees
and here i have used a title called role
of players participated
that will have a font size of 15 and
finally i am saying plt dot plot
so let me just run it
there you go so here we have a nice
pie chart or a pie plot so you can see
the different pies here
we have all-rounder wicket keeper
batter and bowler
so majorly
there are all rounders in the auction
followed by bowlers then we have 17.69
percent batters and 10.11 percent wicket
keepers which is the lowest
cool
now
we are going to create another bar plot
or a bar graph that will tell us how
many players were sold and unsold
so for this i am going to use a count
plot so we will create two bars one for
sold and the other one for unsold
and each of the bars will have different
colors
one will have orange the other one will
have pink and i am using labels so to
label the x-axis and y-axis i have sold
or unsold by label will have number of
players the title of my bar graph would
be sold versus unsold i am given a font
size of 15 and i am saying
plt dot plot now the function that you
see here at the bottom
will display the data labels for each of
the bars
let me just run it and show you the
result there you go
so i have used a figure size of 10 comma
5.
all right now you can see we have a
really good
bar plot which says there were total 237
players sold and 396 players were unsold
as per the data we have
cool
now
you can also
print
the total sold and unsold values let me
show you how to do it
i'll say ipl
dot we can use the group by function
and i want to group it by
status column
and
the value that i want to measure is
the players
count
so i'll say players
rather player
and then i'm going to use the
count function if i run this you can see
here
i've successfully grouped the unsold and
sold players the values are matching
with
the bar plot that we just created so
sold where 237 players are unsold are
396.
cool
now
we are going to see the total number of
players bought by each team again this
is going to be a count plot so basically
a bar plot
so here the condition i'm passing is
in the teams column the value shouldn't
be unsold
so
players bought means the value should be
sold so here i'm using this condition
and the rest of the things remains the
same
one improvement
i have done here is i'm using x6
rotation equal to 70 degrees this
basically means the x labels would be
tilted by 70 degrees
now let's see
the bar plot there you go so here you
can see i have the title players bought
by each team on the y-axis we have the
number of players
and on the x-axis you can see the values
have been tilted by
70 degrees let me just zoom in so that
you can see it better
and this is the bar plot
so the maximum a team can purchase is 25
players some of the teams have also
purchased 24 22 and 23 players let me
just
show you so
gujarat titans have totally purchased 22
players
then
delhi capitals have totaled 24 players
in their squad
again
lucknow supergiants have 22 players
if i scroll and see again
bangalore royal challengers or rcb
they're all challenges bangalore have
22 players in the team and rajasthan
royals and sandra's hyderabad have
24 and 23 players respectively in their
teams
all right
now
we will create three more columns
called
retention
base price
and base price unit
for that
first of all i am creating a new column
called retention which is equal to
ipl base price let me just run it
and then
i'm going to replace
these values that are present in the
list 2 crore 40 lakh 20 lakh 1 crore 30
lakh 1.5 crore
with from auction
and i'm saying in place equal to true
let me just run it
then we are going to
treat the base price
so here
in the base price
column i'm going to replace draft pick
value as 0 so let's run that as well
and now
i'm going to split
the base price
value into two separate values called
bree spice unit and base price so
basically i'm splitting
on this piece
that i have let me show you how it is
going to split
so this is let's see our base price
column
what i did was i
replaced the draft pick values to zero
and then the rest of the values will be
split into two columns called base price
unit so basically it will have the
unit
of the base price let's say crores or
lakhs
and
the base underscore price column will
have the value which is 2 here 40
20 20 so on and so forth
let me just scroll down
and
run that particular cell
now to create
these two columns the base price unit
column and the base underscore price
column i have used the lambda function
and i'm splitting based on the space
let's just run it
now i have replaced
retained with 0
and
let me show you the
final data frame that i have
so here you can see we have replaced
the draft pick values in the base price
column to 0
and on the right side you can see the
three different columns that i wanted to
create
so one is called retention
so zeroes refer to draft pick
any other value
will say
the player was picked from the auction
then you have the base price
unit so here
you can see crores
lacks
and the value base prices 2
40 so on and so forth
cool
choose from over 300 in demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
now
let's check how many players were
retained and bought from the auction by
each of the teams
so i'll say
ipl let me just scroll down
dot i'm going to use the
group by function
then i'll say
team
comma
retention
then i am going to
use the value
as
retention because i want to find the
count of
retained players
then i'll say colon
-1
let me run it
you can see here
the different team names because i have
grouped by team and then retention so i
have changed super kings
from the auction they had picked
21 players and they had retained
four players coming to delhi capitals
delhi capitals in the 2022
ipl auction they picked total 20 players
and they have retained four similarly if
i scroll down let me talk about let's
say punjab kings they have
pegged 23 players from the auction and
retained two players from
the team last year
talking about
rcb or all challenges bangalore they
have picked 19 players from the auction
and they have retained
three players
all right
now in the next cell of code
we are going to display the players in
each team
based on the different types of players
so let me just run it and show you the
result
so here i am using the same condition
the value shouldn't be equal to
unsold
and i am going to use another parameter
called hue for the different colors so
here i have used hue
as type because i want to
show the players in each team based on
the different types
again i have given my
title to the bar plot
and then i have the x label the y label
and my rotation is 50 degrees now
if i scroll down you can see the
different
types of players here is the legend so
blue is for blue
orange or yellow is for all rounder
green is for batter and red
which also looks like maroon is for we
get keepers
and on the
x axis you can see the different team
names
all right
now let's answer another
couple of questions so here i have
what is the highest amount spent on a
single player by each team
so to solve this question i'll say
my data frame name that is ipl
then i'm going to say
retention
equal to equal to
this should be from auction because
you want to see the highest amount spent
and not
from the retained players
then i'm going to
group
by
i'll say
team
and then
i'll say
cost
in
let me just copy it from here
cost in rupees
that is in crores
and
i'll say
max
colon
-1
dot
sort underscore
values
i'll say ascending
equal to false which means i want the
sorted
result in descending order
okay
let me just
bring this
to the left side and we'll run it
there seems to be some error let me
check the error it sees
there's a spelling mistake this should
be
team
let me run it again there you go
so you can see
mumbai indians
have spent
15.25 crores
for one of the players and
this player happens to be shan kissin
then
chennai super kings have spent the
highest amount for
a player who happens to be a bowler the
name is deepak chahar they have bought
him for 14 crores kolkata knight riders
bought
shreya's air for 12.25 crores
and so on and so forth
so these are the highest amounts spent
on a single player by each of the teams
let me scroll down
now we are going to see the player
retained at maximum value or maximum
price
now if you follow ipl the maximum
price
at which a player was retained happens
to be ravindra jadeja so let's see at
what price was he retained
i'll say
retention
equal to equal to
i'll say
retained then i'll say
sort underscore
values
by equal to
i'll use the
same column
cost in
rupees
that's in crores
i'll say
ascending equal to
false
dot
head and i want to find the top player
again there's some error
let's see
where is the error
she's ascending equal to false
dot head
okay this should be
sort underscore
values
within bracket i should
say buy
i think this should be
fine now let's run it
there you go
so you can see here our result is player
name ravindra jadeja who was retained
for
16 crores by chennai super kings
cool
now
the next cell of code will
display or print the top 5 bowlers who
have been picked
in this year's ipl based on
their cost in inr
let me just run it and show you the
result
you can see here deepak chahar went for
14 crores then we have shradler who was
bought by
delhi capitals earlier he was part of
csk
for 10.75 crores then we have prasith
krishna who has been bought by rajasthan
royals this time
last year he was with kekiar and he has
been bought for 10 crores similarly loki
ferguson has been bought by gujarat
titans
and he played for kkr last season he has
been bought for 10 crores while his base
price was too close then we have avish
khan
you can see avishkhan's base price was
just 20 lakhs and he has been bought for
10 crores by lucknow super giants again
and last year he was part of the delhi
capitals
now you can replace
this value
suppose let's say you want to find the
top five batsman's picked or batters
picked with the highest amount you can
just see
batter instead of bowler and if i run
this
you can see here
srya sayer was bought by
kolkata night riders for 12.25 crores
last year he was part of delhi capitals
then you have
shrimran hitmayo who's from
west indies he has been
picked by the rajasthan royals for
8.5 crores then we have rahul tribati
shikha dhaban and devdat particle
now if you wanted to check for
let's say all rounders
you can replace batter with all-rounder
if i run this
you can see
lamb living stone has been bought by
punjab kings this season
for
11.5 crores his beast price was just one
crore and last year he was part of the
rajasthan royals
then we have a player from sri lanka
asuranga then we have hershel patel
shahrukh khan and rahul
devatia who have been
the top five all-rounders picked at
highest amount
cool
finally
we want to see the players who were part
of the ipl last season but were not
picked for this year's ipl
so for that what i'm doing is first i'm
renaming my
2021 squad column
this column i want to
rename it as previous team
let's run it
then
i am going to find out the unsold
players so here i am saying previous
team not equal to
not participated
and then
i'm using another condition team should
be equal to equal to unsold and i'm
going to find out only the player and
the previous team
so let's run it and see the result
so here you can see
these players were part of the ipl last
season but
they haven't been picked this season and
last season they had played for let's
say surah shriner played for csk steve
smith was part of the delhi capitals
sakib al-hashan
was part of kkr if i scroll down you
have david malan who played for punjab
kings in 2021
oin morgan
who played for kkr he also captained kkr
but unfortunately he was
not picked this season chris lynn from
australia also
remained unsold this season
and to tie we have been cutting aditya
there are other players as well
you have kane richardson dhawal kulkarni
cool so these were the players who were
part of the ipl season 2021 but
unfortunately were not picked and
remained unsold for 2022 season
cool
and that brings us to our
end of this demo session on
ipl data analysis 2022 so we learned
how to use the different functions
and attributes that are part of
the
python libraries and we manipulated the
data we visualized the data and
answered some specific questions
in this video we'll be using four
publicly available data sets about
formula one that has information from
1950 to the 2019 f1 season
we'll see how using the python libraries
you can perform explority data analysis
and draw valuable insights
so let's begin by understanding what
formula one is
formula one also known as f1 is a
motorsport defined by open wheeled
single single-seat race cars
it features the best drivers in the most
powerful and technically advanced cars
the sport is governed by the fia that is
international automobile federation
here 10 teams comprising of two drivers
each compete in a series of races over a
period of one year to find out the
ultimate driver and a constructor
champion
in our demonstration we'll be using four
data sets let me show them one by one
these are all csv files
now this is the first data set that
we'll be using in our demo
so if you notice the data set does not
have columns
names in fact none of the data sets have
column names so while importing the data
set we'll assign the column names using
the names parameter
i'll show that in a
while
now this is the results data set
the results data set has information
about
the result id
then we have the race id driver id
we have
the constructor id
grid position
then we also have information about the
fastest
lap then we also have information about
rank
the fastest lap speed
and the status id
now moving on to the second data set
which is about
races
now this is the second data set which is
about races so
it has information about the race id
the year in which the race was held then
we have
the round number circuit id
then the name of the
grand prix so you can see here australia
and malaysia and chinese spanish monaco
turkish british german
and others
then we have the
date on which the gp was held or the
grand prix was held
we have the time
and a url which basically leads to the
wikipedia page of that particular
grand prix for that year
now moving on to our third data set
so this is our third data set which is
about
drivers
now it has the driver id the name of the
driver you can see here hamilton
rossberg alonso
ryken
then we have sato
masa
button weber and all
after that we have the
number code
then we have the
phone name of the driver the surname of
the driver
and then we have the date of birth of
that particular driver we have the
nationality as well
we have the wikipedia page
for the
driver
now moving on to the last data set which
is about
constructors
so this is the fourth and the final data
set that we'll be using in our data
analysis project
so here we have the constructor id
then the constructor reference
in formula one
and this is the actual name of the
constructor so we have mclaren
we have
bmw sauber williams then we have ferrari
toyota red bull force india
we also have jordan jaguar and all
next we have the
nationality and the url
that is the wikipedia page of
that particular constructor
now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and we'll start with our
analysis
here is my jupyter notebook that i'll be
using for this demo you can see some of
the cells are already filled this is
just to make sure we
save some time
so using these data sets that we just
saw and our libraries such as numpy
pandas matplotlib and c bond
we'll answer specific questions such as
the drivers and constructors who have
been the most successful throughout the
history of f1 sport
then we'll explore the impact of
starting and finishing positions and if
the speed of the cars has changed over
the years
so let's begin with our analysis
first and foremost we are going to
import all the necessary libraries so
here i am importing numpy pandas
matplotlib and cbon
and after that i am writing percentage
matplotlib inline
that is to ensure that
all the plots are embedded in line i'll
hit shift enter to run it
take some time there you go so we have
successfully imported all the libraries
now the next step is to
load the data and assign
column names
so
i load my
first data which is results i'll say pd
dot
read underscore
csv
i'll give my
file name which is results dot
csv
and then using the
names parameter
i'll pass in the
column names so actually i have written
the column names in a notepad let me
open that
so i have this f1
notepad created which has the column
names i'll just start copying
the column names
within the names parameter i'll paste it
if i scroll to the right you can see the
different column names that
have been assigned
and
that
i'm going to say
comma
and i'll write
header equal to none
i'll close the bracket
cool
similarly let's import the second data
set which is about
races i'll say
pd dot
read underscore csv
i'll give my
file name which is racist.csv
and then
i'll give the
names parameter this is actually names
and not name
okay i'm going to
copy the
second line
and i'll paste it here
and again
i'll say
header
equal to none
next
we'll import our third data set which is
about
drivers
so i'll say pd dot read underscore csv
i'll say
drivos.csv
then
again use the
names parameter
and i'll copy the
third line now which has the column
names
for the
drivers data set
here
i need to give
another parameter which is
header
equal to
none
finally we are going to import
our constructors data set
it's a constructors equal to pd dot
read underscore csv which is the
function present in the pandas library
i'll say
constructors dot csv which is my
file name
and then again i'll use the names
parameter
i'll go to my notepad and this time i'll
copy the
fourth line which has the column names
for the constructors data set
i'll paste it
and
here i'll give my
final parameter that is header equal to
none
all right
now
let me hit shift enter to
run it
okay we see some error here let's debug
the error it says
no such file or directory drivers dot
csv
let's see
where was the issue
this should be
driver.csv
now we have successfully loaded the data
and assigned the
columns to the various data sets
now the
next analysis
is to merge all the data set
so here i'll create a data frame called
df and i'll use
pd dot
merge function
first i'll use the
results data frame that we just
imported above
this one
and
i'm going to merge it with
races data frame
and from the resist data frame i am
going to take
specific columns like the
race id
then
i need the
year
after that i need name
next
i'm going to take
the round column as well
and
i'm going to use
on parameter so
on parameter
is actually
the column that is common to both the
data frames that is results and races so
here my common column
is going to be the race id because it is
present in both the data sets
and i would like to merge
so for that i'm going to use how so i am
going to use a left join
so
if you know sql you will be aware of
left join it takes all the rows from the
left table
and only the matching rows from the
right table
again going to use the merge function so
i'll write
df equal to pd dot
merge
i'll say
df comma and now i'm going to
merge the
divorce data set
and
i'm going to select
specific columns so i will say
driver id
make sure there are no spelling mistakes
in the
column names
then i'll say
driver
rdf which is the name of the driver or
reference
comma
and then i want the
nationality of the
driver
all right
we'll give a comma i'll say on
which column i want to merge so here the
common column
is going to be the driver id
again
how
is going to be a left join
into the final
merge part i'll say again df equal to pd
dot
merge
i'll pass in my data frame and my final
data set which i have is about
constructors
from constructors we are going to choose
specific columns so i'll take the
constructor
id
then
i'll take
the name column
and again the
nationality column of the
manufacturer
here i'll say
on
equal to
the common column i'll use is
constructor id
you give a comma and say how
equal to
left again
cool
make sure
you're merging it with the
right column names so let's run this
cell to merge
all the four data sets
i'll hit click enter
oops there is some error let's see it
says constructor
id index
okay there's a spelling mistake this
should be
constructor id cool
let's run it
there you go
now
the next thing we want to do is to drop
the unnecessary columns
so i'll say df.drop
within the drop function
we are going to pass in the
column names i'll say
number
then we also don't want the
position column
next we have
position underscore
text
after that we have
labs
next we are going to drop
fastest
lap
then we will also drop the
status id
comma we'll drop the
result underscore id column
then
going to drop the race underscore id
column
we'll also drop
driver underscore id column
and finally we are going to drop
the
constructor underscore id column
and i'll say access equal to
1
and in place i'll c equal to true
because i want to remove it from my
original data frame that is df
there you go
now the next
thing i want to do is i want to rename
some of the columns so i'll say df dot
rename
i'll say
columns equal to now we are going to
pass in a dictionary
i'm going to change the
rank
to
test
underscore lab underscore rank
let me give a comma
now i'll say
name underscore x
equal to
i'll say the
grand prix name so i'll say gp
underscore name
next column i'm going to focus is
the nationality column so i'll say
nationality underscore
x
i'll give a colon the value i'm going to
pass in is
driver nationality
all right
up next
we have one column called
underscore
y
and that i'm going to change it to
constructor name
another comma
i'm going to say
nationality
underscore
y
colon
change it to
constructor nationality
underscore nationality
finally we have
driver
underscore ref column
and that i'm going to replace with
just
driver
finally i'll say
in place
equal to
true
well just verify if all the column names
are correct
let's run it
all right so now we have
successfully renamed
the columns
after that
in the next cell i'm going to rearrange
the columns so here i'm
using the same data frame and we have
just renamed the columns so starting
with your
grand pre name round driver
nationality
and others
let's run this
up next
we're going to drop the
2019 season data because
it is incomplete
so i'll say df equal to
df
then i'll see
here
not
equal to
2090
let's see how to
sort the values so i'll say df equal to
df.sort
underscore values which is the function
name
i am going to sort it by
here
followed by
round
followed by
the
position
underscore
order
comma i'll say
ascending
equal to
first let's say is false
next i have true
and then
i'll have true
all right
moving ahead
now we are going to see how to replace
the
put slash
n values in the time column with
something called nan because the time
column was not registered when a driver
did not finish a raise or was lagged by
another driver
so to do this i am going to say
df dot
time
dot i'm going to use the replace
function
and here i'll say
forward slash
or backward slash
n
and i'm going to replace with
numpies nan
i'll say
in place equal to true
let me just copy this because we are
going to use the same
emitters
next i'm going to replace the
value
milliseconds dot
replace i'll paste it here
then i'll say df
dot fastest
underscore lab underscore
rank dot
replace
paste it
next i have
d up dot
fastest dot
lap
dot
time
theory please
to that i have
the next column which is
speed so i'll say fastest
underscore
lap underscore
speed
replace
and paste it
so here
i'm going to replace
this particular value
the
backward slash n with
nan
let me run it
cool
step i'm going to
change the data types for
fastest underscore lab underscore speed
to float then fastest underscore lab
underscore rank to float again
now
problem here is we cannot convert it
into an integer because there are
missing values so we are going to change
it to float
again for milliseconds also we are
changing it to float values
let me run it
now
i'll reset the index
let me show you how to reset the index
i'll say df dot
reset
underscore
index
i'll say
drop
equal to
true
give a comma and say
in place equal to true
all right
that we have
done our initial
processing step of the data set
now we'll check the shape of the data
set then we see all the data sets the
total number of non-null values the
memory usage and we'll
check the head of the data set
now to see the total number of
rows and columns i'll say
print df dot shape
you can see here there are total 24
197 rows in my data set and there are
total of 15 columns
now let's use
df dot
info function
so it gives me the
year the grand prix name
the round number
driver constructor name grid position
order total number of points
time
then time in milliseconds the fastest
lap rank
the fastest lap speed
the nationality of the driver the
nationality of the constructor
then here we have the
total number of non-null objects
and then you also have the memory usage
at the bottom
finally let's see the
head of the data frame so i'll say
df dot
head let's say i want to check the first
10 rows
where you go
if i scroll down you can see here we
have the top 10 rows printed
and you have the year the grand prix
name round driver constructor name and
other columns now let me just
brief you about what these column names
stand for
so the year column that you see here is
the season that the grand prix took
place and then we have the
name of the grand prix
now the round column is the number of
the race in each season for example one
means it was the first race of the
season and then two means it was the
second race of the season so so on and
so forth
then we have the name of the driver
that we have the
name of the car constructor so you can
see ferrari mercedes red bull renault
then we have the grid that is the
starting position before the race
actually this depends on the
qualifications which occur one day
before the race
then we have the position underscore
order column this means the final
position at the end of the race
then we have the points column that is
the total number of points scored in the
race
next we have the time that is the amount
of time that took to finish the race
only the winners time is displayed and
drivers behind the winner are shown how
far behind the winner they are
then we have the milliseconds column
that is the amount of time that took to
finish the race in milliseconds
if i just scroll down
i'll just move to the
right
go to the top
then we have the fastest underscore lab
underscore rank that is the order of the
fastest lab during race
next we have
fastest lap time that is the shortest
amount of time that took to complete a
lap in the release
then we have the lap speed that is the
average speed of the
fastest lap
then we have the
country to which the driver belongs to
and then we have the
constructor nationality that is the
country where the car constructor is
based out of
okay
now
here i'm going to
set my figure size to 10 comma 6 this is
going to be for all the
plots that we are going to create
afterwards
cool
we'll create a data frame that will have
all the grand prix winners
so here i'm going to say
driver
underscore
winner equal to
use my data frame
df dot i'll say loc
then i'll say
df
i want
the position underscore
order
and that should be equal to 1 so which
means
the driver 1 degrees
and then
i'm going to
use the
group by function
i'm going to group it by
driver
and
for values i'll say
position underscore
order
use the
count function
followed by
sort underscore
values
i'll say
ascending equal to
false
it change it to
two underscore
frame
dot
reset
underscore
index
what essentially i am doing here is i am
finding out
all the drivers that have participated
and
next
i'm going to create a
bar plot so this is going to be the
first visualization of our analysis
so i'll say
sb
which we have taken in our
analysis ideally it should be sns but sb
also will work
so i'll say sb dot
bar plot
i'm going to say data equal to
driver underscore
winner
the y-axis i'll have
driver
in the x-axis i'll have
position
underscore
order
then i have
color equal to
green
that i'll set my
alpha value
to
0.5
or let's say
0.8
then
we are going to
give a title to our plot so i'll say plt
dot
title
let's say most
grand prix
winners in f1
then we are going to label our access so
for y label i will have
driver
name
we have the x label
that will have
number of
grand prix wins
and i'll say
plt dot
y
text
cool
let's run it
and you can see we have our first
bar plot here now the bar plot
shows that there are
a large distribution of
grand cravens
only a few drivers in history
of f1 have won over 20 grand prey in
their careers and there are some drivers
who completely dominated the f1 racing
and have won over
50 grand priest in their careers so we
are going to focus on those
top five or top 10
drivers
in the next section so what i'm doing
here is
from the
above
result that we just got i'm going to
filter out only the
top 10 so i'm going to use the head
function
and
inside that i passed in 10 if i print it
you can see here
as per the data that we have
we have michael schumacher who
is the position
order leader with 91 gp events then we
have hamilton vettel prost sena
alonso
then we have stevert clerk and lauda
the data that we have is
not the most recent one so if you check
the actual stats hamilton has actually
overtaken michael schumacher and has won
over
103 close to 103 releases as of now
and next we have michael sumacre so this
is not the most recent data
cool
now using this data we'll create another
bar plot for the top 10
drivers so i'll say sb dot
bar plot
i'll say data equal to
the
name that we have used that is top 10
drivers so i'll say top 10
drivers
in the y-axis we'll have
the
driver name
in the x-axis will have
position
underscore
order
for the bars i'm going to use a color
equal to
let's say blue this time
i'll set my alpha value
to be
0.8
and
i'll say let's say
line
width
equal to
0.8
and i'll also give
an edge color of let's say black
follow the same drill i'm going to give
a title to my plot so i'll say plt dot
title
most gp
winners in a phone
will give a y label
that says
driver
name and then i'll have
x label which will have
number of
on pre bins
let me see if everything is fine
and then we'll
run this there you go
you can see we have a very nice
horizontal
bar plot that shows the
top drivers in f1 so as per our data
that we have we have michael schumacher
who has won over 91 or close to
91
races then we have hamilton vettel
alonso clark and others
all right
in the same way we are going to create
bar plot for the top constructors that
have participated in f1
so here i'm finding out
all the
constructor winners so here
i'm using my position underscore order
equal to equal to 1 and then i'm using
the group by
based on the constructor name
and then i'm finding the count of
position order and sorting the values
in
descending order and i'm changing it to
frame or to a data frame
and to create my bar plot i'm using the
bar plot function the data which is
constructor underscore winner
in the y-axis i'll have the constructor
name on the x-axis i'll have the
position order
so you can see here i've used color as
pink and i've given a title x label by
label
and vertex
let's run it
there you go so here you can see again
the data is
widely
spread
so we have a lot of constructor names
now
our next task is to
check the
top 10 gpa constructor windows so here
i'm using the head function and finding
out the top 10 if i run it
you can see here
the manufacturing companies or the
constructors who have won the most
number of
reese's
are ferrari
mclaren williams then we have mercedes
red bull tim lotus renault
and others
okay
now we'll convert this data into a
horizontal
bar graph or a bar chart
so that will show the bar plot for the
top 10
constructors
now let me show you how to do it
so i'll say
sb which is for c bond dot
bar plot
i'm going to say data equal to
top 10 let me just confirm
the name we have top 10 constructors
scroll down i'll say constructors
y-axis i'll have constructor
on the x-axis i'll have
position underscore order
then
i'll say
color
equal to let's say we'll use the
red color for the bars then i'll set my
alpha to
0.8
i'll say
line width equal to
0.8
and my
edge
color i'll say
black
that i'll say plt dot
title
top 10
most
gp
wins
lt dot
by label would be
constructor
name
and i'll have plt dot
x label
as
number of
gp
bins
cool
let's run it
there you go so here you can see we have
ferrari at the top then we have mclaren
williams most cities i'm pretty certain
by
the end of 2021 season mercedes would
have gained a lot of wins
since
hamilton has been on the top
for mercedes for quite some time now
all right
now
finally we are going to
create a
regression plot that will
show how
two variables that is the starting
position and finishing
position
vary
so to do that i am going to exclude the
data points with grid 0 because it skews
the data so 0 means that the driver
started from the
pit lane
so
i'm using this function called reg plot
to plot my
regression line
let me run it and show you the result
there you go
so if you see here
we can easily see there's a linear
relationship between the
starting and
finishing position so on the x-axis we
have the starting position on the y-axis
we have the
finishing or the finished place
so which is what is actually expected
right
now we can also see that
most races had up to
25 drivers you can see the density of
the points here
but
some of the recess also had over 30
drivers you can see the
light color blue dots
next
we are going to
check whether the speed of the cars
changed over the years since this data
is only available from 2004 onwards so
we have
we have taken
years that start from 2004 onwards
now let me show you the result
of this data
so essentially we are plotting the
average speed among
all teams during the fastest lap at
individual grand prix and here on the
y axis you have the average fastest
speed in kilometer per hour and then you
have the different
gps
and
you can see here the year values
now
in general what we see is there's a
decrease in the average fastest lap from
2004
till around
2015
for almost all the circuits
and again from 2015 onward the speed
started
to increase
you can see here there's an increase
after 2015 there's an increase there's
an increase here as well
you can also notice that
the speed is very different on each
track for instance if you check the
italian grand prix which is here
italian gp has the
fastest race in the calendar with
average speed exceeding over
240 kilometers per hour on the other
hand if you
talk about the
monaco grand prix let me show you if you
see here
the monaco gp is the slowest race with
average speed below 160 kilometer per
hour now this is actually expected
because the monaco grand prix
has very narrow streets and
hence the drivers cannot
drive fast in this circuit
all right
so
that brings us to the end of our
explorative data analysis on the formula
one datasets
i hope it was useful and informative
if you have any queries please feel free
to put them in the comments section of
the video thanks again stay safe and
keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you